area now before we get started you guys
already know okay if you have watched
two or more of our videos and you have
not subscribed then we have what
beef tell em
beef tell us okay if you have not
subscribed and you've watched your
videos we've got beef right so i am sara
garvey i am here with my apparent bae
uh pearl right that's the word on the
streets is that me and pearl are out
together now so i'm doing this show with
my bae right pearl right bae
what are you talking about
we today are talking about
father's rights and uh the drama that
comes with being a father and being a
baby mama
as well pearl okay guys um
pipe down sorry okay so guys don't
forget to like the video it really helps
with the algorithm um i i'm not sure how
many people we have in here right now
but i want 50 of you to like it while
you're at it sign up for our memberships
for exclusive behind the scenes content
we're coming out with a vlog this
week um also subscribe to the channel
guys we're trying to get to 200k subs
and each and every one of you helps so
to start
why don't doesn't everyone go around and
introduce themselves say your name your
age your relationship status and if you
have children yes
my name is sean
i'm engaged
i'm 41 years old
children yeah three children
i forgot that
hey i'm yasmin i'm 32
i'm engaged and i have one son
hi um my name is jamella i go by jam
i'm single and i don't have any children
oh i'm 25.
hi my name's chanel i'm 22
i'm in a relationship and i don't have
children
yeah my name's amiri i'm 300 335.
i'm single
you say you've got any children yeah
i've got kids how many two daughters
okay so today guys we're going to be
talking about
being a father
and also being a mother i'm going to
read you something before we get started
according to the fathers for justice
website
200 children
per day
are removed from their father by the
family court system in the u
k
that means that there are nearly four
million
fatherless children in the uk
at the moment
sean
you
run a
an organization right would i be correct
i would say i'm more of an activist
you're more of an activist i'm i'm
trying to create one at the moment
called equal start okay can you tell us
a little bit more about that when it
comes to fathers
well with me i've been campaigning since
2013 before i had trouble with my oldest
son obviously to get equal rights for
fathers in terms of parent or alienation
as you know we suffer disproportionately
from it
and i just want to make a difference in
actually getting out there and spreading
awareness
showing that we have you know
the right to parent as just as much as
mothers
so what about that stat about
200 um children per day being removed by
the family court system is that like a
is that something you come across really
no not really i've never really seen
that myself i've more seen four hundred
thousand single fathers raising their
children that's what i like to focus on
right it's just that crazy
gathered by nutmeg an organization that
shows you the positives of fatherhood in
the uk
but obviously something like that it
would be shocking to me 200 a day that's
outlandish
when you said that um you were having
trouble with your like
with your do you say your son you're my
oldest son what do you mean
well i don't see him much in the moment
when strange and a lot of the bedrock
behind that is
because of the typical problems that you
see in the uk in family breakdown
typical problems you're gonna have to
elaborate on that one
well
my first mother when we got together um
it was a casual thing
um before we slept together
i said look what is your goals and
priorities in life and she was at
university at the time so was i but she
were there two george and i didn't have
any
so i said look um you're one of four
mistresses
so
are you gonna
part with it or i'm telling you from
there i'll tell you my vices are my
virtues so she said that's why and
you're being straightforward with me
six weeks later she told me she was
pregnant and said you sure is it mine
that can't be right i said we're gonna
have to look into this so
throughout the pregnancy there was a lot
of back and forth and i was you know in
two minutes said you know whether
or whether i should say get in the bush
you know will i look like a monster so i
was torn it was traumatized me to be
fair
and that i had a dream once that um
my son being in the womb
i woke up and said oh please don't kill
me daddy so i said you know what don't
have it i went and it was the first born
son so i was pleased so i said yeah i
have to have the child
um came along now 18 months
felt like 18 years
back and forth
you know family corruption i didn't like
the way she interacted with her siblings
and her parents
um i didn't like the way she handed her
first two children she introduced them
to me to me far too soon the way i saw
it and from then was at loggerheads and
it never got any better it just got
worse and worse to like to terminate the
relationship but then if you're like if
she's introduced like just if she's
introducing to her
children too soon
why did you kind of no by that time i
was um i was pretty promised because
that time
and
it's one of those things lack of
discipline and bad choices and because i
thought i told her my stance is i don't
want any children so i'll get married
she probably thought here comes muggins
i'm gonna get him
yeah see so you think you got played
yeah yeah i think so i would say so
you've got two children already at the
time
she wasn't even 24 yeah
and i was not even 25. so i said why
would you want to have you've got two
children already with different men why
would you want to i went to university
i'm living in shared housing you still
live home with your mother why would you
want me to um be the third one i said
were you trying to be eureka johnson
if you no one doesn't know that pun
she's a swedish
former host i used to be on gladiators
she's got four children four different
men
so obviously i was mocking her like that
but
in the day she we yeah we tried
he didn't make it much but
let's see how to get rid of it do you
think that's common where women try to
get pregnant by a guy that doesn't want
to wife them
well i haven't got no stats around it
but in my sphere like just from
anecdotal evidence
nothing yeah what do you guys think
nothing that's true i think so
i definitely have heard stories from
guys who say that the woman has tried to
trap them
um so i do think it's pretty common
it's very common do women admit to
trapping guys never i've never heard a
woman admit to trapping a guy maybe not
to a guy
yeah cause my gut just tells me as a
girl like we have so many forms of
contraception so if you really don't
want to get pregnant by a guy like
you'll make you'll make damn sure that
you do not get pregnant by the wrong guy
i agree but then again like if it
happens by accident
like say a girl's on a pill and she ends
up getting pregnant and she's against
abortion then
you know
that could happen
but i don't think it's very common yeah
it seems like it's more like the
exception rather than the rule
to the co-parents here though
how is co-parenting is it an easy
process or a hard process
oh
um i would say
it starts off
as a hard process and you do have to
sometimes go back and forth back and
forth and then you finally get to that
to that point might be taking months and
years
um to get to that point of just
understanding and realizing what the
main
you know issue is and what the
responsibility is and what you need to
do
speaking personally i think with my
situation
i was with my son's dad for
six years
and it didn't work out you know and um
and obviously because i've ended the
relationship he wasn't very
happy and he still was trying
but then because i didn't want to
he didn't want to take
because we weren't together he didn't
want to do his part of being a being of
dad so
when it's like that it's definitely
challenging and um
yeah you just have to kind of
stick at it you give them the the
conditions of look this is how it's
going to be are you able to do that if
not i'm going to continue doing what i'm
doing until you realize
the situation so i do agree that
some people have a nice flow process of
it but some people they it depends on
how that relationship was and how you
broke how you broken up and
and if you know you can be civilized
about it when you say you gave him like
this is what's going to go on yeah
um as a father myself yeah and i don't
know if the fathers can testify to it a
lot of the time
women
create hoops for fathers to jump through
and if those fathers do not jump through
those hoops the way the woman wants the
father to jump through them then they
make it difficult
for the father to see the child
yes some people do
but for myself because it was i was like
look sort yourself out get yourself your
place you got the time i'm not going to
rush you so get yourself a job sort
yourself out and you know um and yeah
when you can
find a proper place to stay and you can
have him then you you're welcome to i
wasn't very
pushy i wasn't asking for money i was
just getting on with it because at the
end of the day i had that's how it is i
think it depends on your circumstances
and what you're and what yeah and who
who broke up with who as well can i ask
you something no i mean
so you said you broke up with him yeah
yeah
how long after the kid was born did you
break up with him
um i'll say about
about five
five years old yeah five years after
so
when when what it was a marriage like
ever yeah i was i was engaged and
everything um and then i got and then i
fell pregnant so i was engaged and then
i got pregnant
two months after
and did you consult any of your like
male
like family as to if you should
go in that direction you know what um
not really i think how how it was
was um
yeah it wasn't something to discuss with
the family i wasn't really
you know i'm not really
close in that sense
you say that but that's
well in hindsight now you could be why
you should have went to the family if
you get what i mean
the reasons why we broke up was just our
own relationship he was also he was a
good dad we broke up you broke up with
him yes because of because there was you
know layers of things that were going on
and i'm not gonna he was willing to
sacrifice your child growing up in a
relationship with two parents as
supposed to your happiness
not really because um due to personal
reasons i've had to that was the
decision i had to make
and i do feel like um
he's
been he's he's how he was as a dad was
not questionable i knew he was good with
his son and everything but it was an
ongoing situation that had to
had to be best for the home as well i
had to look at
every angle you can't just be like you
know stay in a situation that may not be
healthy for for for the child you see
now we're getting you know i mean you've
got to be you're talking about like um
assault
what do you mean
domestic abuse oh no no no i'm not
talking about domestic abuse but i'm
just saying that
when you both are not on the same page
and it's not working in the household
you do have to make a decision
do you know what i mean i think it's
interesting that like we say we speak on
the show all the time about um
the divorce rates and breakup rates in
the uk is 64 percent of
relationships marriages specifically
women are the ones to initiate the
breakup in america is as high as 80
percent ninety percent of your colleges
ninety percent if you're college
educated yeah so if women are the ones
breaking off these relationships um
and then making it hard for the father
it's a double-edged sword do you know
what i mean like so fathers are being
broken up with and also
they are now being um told that they
can't see their children the way they
want to see their children well i think
in the in the u.s
women win custody cases it's either 70
or 80 of the time
and it's kind of like why is that
it's because women normally kick the man
out the house if if you okay if we
establish a routine of me having the kid
before i leave the house then you can't
have full custody of the kid
so what typically men make the mistake
and do is they leave the house with the
woman and the kid and then now you're
responsible for
um paying for the child right and then
she can go to court and say that he
wasn't involved even if she was keeping
him away from the kid and um the other
thing that i learned the other day in
the u.s at least um
you're entitled to 25
for one kid of a man's income and that's
after um
that's like leftover income so it's not
even taxed
so
a lot of guys get into really bad
financial situations because they make a
certain amount of money and she gets 25
even 50 if it's more than one kid of his
income say he loses the job he still has
to pay and it could be months before he
gets it changed now he's thousands of
dollars in debt
and on top of that if she's withholding
the kid then she he had to pay thousands
of dollars in court to go see his kid so
a lot of times breaking up the family
leaves a lot of men in like financial
ruins i know and depressed suicidal go
ahead yeah sorry i know there was
someone on the show before and i know i
interviewed him myself for for on my
channel and he had spent upwards of 25k
just trying to see his child in the
family court system because he was
dealing with a mother who um you know
was trying to alienate him from his
child and i think a lot of the time when
it comes to fathers and mothers one
thing that's not spoken about the
deadbeat dad narrative is spoken about a
lot we've heard it for like decades but
what we don't hear about is like
deadbeat mothers mothers that are
alienating their children from their
actual fathers
do you know what i mean and i think i
think that needs to be spoken about a
lot because i think when it comes to
when it comes to mothers like i said
we're jumping through the hoops if you
don't do what they say
then you're a deadbeat dad and they'll
go around spreading around around the
whole town to your family friends that
you're a deadbeat dad why but just
because you didn't want to jump through
the hoops that she set but that's okay
like so there's
okay
you see some women
like
they would say that about
any of their baby father if they're not
with them typically if they say it's
their friends or whatever
but if you are like
you like the guy
and you had the baby without him even
wanting the baby
with so now we're talking about fathers
that want to be in the life we're not
even the kids is not even here yet i did
not want to have a kid with you
and you had the kid anyway
and now i'm forced to look after the kid
and you don't understand as a woman how
it feels because you've had the kid
inside of your belly for so long so
you're so attached so you don't
understand like why doesn't he
why isn't he like doesn't he love the
kid it's like men carry so much visceral
from women that actually like
trapped them
and it might not necessarily that i
don't
like
necessarily want to see the kid but
every time i see your face
it reminds me of
what you did do you get i'm trying to
say it's like
the kid is more of a like um
like the kid ends up getting hurt but
it's more of a extra as opposed to the
relationship so that's why when i said
to her like did you leave the
relationship it's like why would you
have a kid with me if you're gonna leave
me bro
but people don't intend people don't
plan those kind of things
situations happen why have the kid then
you know and when we get married
you know even if you get married things
do happen yeah but if you get married
then it's like you're not making a kid
out of wedlock so if i'm if i go if
you've got a ring on you and i've got a
ring on me you have more responsibility
as a woman to be more to take on crap or
jimmy because what you've got to
understand yeah is that
sometimes
when men say stuff like that they're
saying well yeah you can't you can't
just get up and go because you're
married yeah but it shouldn't be used as
that we shouldn't be looking at that
angle and we shouldn't be using it for
that do you see what i mean you chose
the man so yeah and obviously again so
it's not like you're in jail you chose
the man and we're still entitled to to
if things aren't working entitled to
leave the situation i think the question
is at what point is your happiness more
important than the kids yeah because
when you you raise a kid in a single
parent home you're putting your kid at
every statistical disadvantage but then
and so i'm not i'm not saying women
should be able to take anything but i
think it begs the question and i don't
know your personal situation but at what
cost
so like at what cost is your personal
like happiness above your kids
i think it when it depends on your
situation in your household but then if
the person as i said is a good dad and
you're
you're not a bitter baby mom you are
allowing them to sort themselves out
they've got their job they've got their
place and now you're co-parenting and
the children
i mean i think there are some bitter
situations where it doesn't end up like
that so then you can be like you know
they're a statistic and blah blah blah
but then again if you've met if you've
got somebody that you know that isn't
that isn't still bitter about it and
they have got their own things going on
and they're not they're not playing
child support because again even with
the child support again
you only get put on child support if
you're not doing what you're meant to be
doing because no you know i mean
anyway we'll get back to that but don't
don't change the goal
i'm gonna get to you because you know
what it is yeah
a lot of women after okay you don't get
married but you want to have a kid i
don't get that so you're willing to
be you you want to be free that's why
you want to be free but you want to have
you want to play um mommy and daddy you
want to you want to play mommy and daddy
but you don't want to be locked down and
i'm saying that you said that not myself
no
no because when you said when you said
um that means i'm controlling it's not
necessarily controlling you if you're
all right would you expect your mom
inside of a rave
dottie winan
on instagram showing her body like your
mom you couldn't even picture it in your
head because that's just different
generation but you've got to remember
these kids that are coming up are going
to have to watch their mum on instagram
doing only fans doing like the other
days but that generation a lot of our
grandparents stayed in situations that
they didn't really want to be in exactly
but we know that but the results are
better yeah
they weren't happy either
but like to me like to me it's always
about the kids yeah so like my
grandparents like i'm not going to put
out their business but there's a lot of
reasons in 2022 a lot of people would
have said they got divorced but they
raised 13 beautiful kids and put that
first yeah and to me there's very few
reasons why and maybe it's because i'm i
don't have kids and maybe i don't
understand i don't know but i just think
there's very few reasons why you would
break up a home yeah especially
especially like if he's got a good job
and he's and he's in the kids lives like
it sounds like he's a good dude but i
also believe that you need to also
be
happy in love and doing it for the right
reasons not just for
financial of course the financial and
generation of wealth is important but if
you can if you are in a position to
separate and still build and still
co-parent and still the child's still
getting the benefits of both families
and still getting that time
getting that time
i don't think that's good and see that
sounds really nice but the problem is
but
no no i'm saying the problem is women
need 2.5 million to retire on one income
and most girls even if they're making
six figures aren't racking that up right
or getting remarried that's that's the
issue
and so and even in the uk i know you
guys have like bailout programs but what
if one day those are gone and poof you
have to figure it out on your own it's
like oh there's gonna women are the
highest growing um homeless population i
think uh uh in my personal opinion i
think a lot of women get sold the fairy
tale version of a relationship
which is why they're the ones to break
off the relationship most of the time i
think the fairytale disney version
hollywood version of a relationship is
what women have been sold and so what
happens is when you get into a
relationship um
you realize that it's actually work it's
not like you saw in a disney program
it's not like you saw it in hollywood
it's not like the films told you
this is work and a lot of women are like
well this is not what i signed up for i
was so that prince charming was going to
come sweep me off my feet give me the
great life 2.5 2.4 children the white
picket fence and doves and rainbows and
all this kind of stuff and then you
realize hang on a minute we got children
we got debts to pay i mean we got a
mortgage all of this stuff and i just
think that a lot of women today have
been sold a hollywood ideal of a
relationship which is the reason why
they're breaking not just breaking off
relationships but breaking families
apart yeah because to me like love
shouldn't really matter when you have
kids
like
do you guys agree or disagree at what
point does a woman have permission to
leave a relationship because it's toxic
you know i i come from a two-parent
household so i don't know if i can speak
too tough on the subject but
if the relationship at home is breaking
down it's not working
what what then um would allow the woman
to leave because children growing up in
a toxic household can't be much better
than people growing up with a single
parent is co-parenting well
you know so like
but the numbers the numbers don't
support what you're saying
so the numbers it's really clear
single-parent households are worse off
than two parent households
and to me personally i would say
cheating if it's like to the crazy right
um i think abuse for sure um but
honestly like most things can be worked
out and if you're in a toxic
relationship like you have to look
internally because it takes two to tango
and you attract what you are thank you
so if you find yourself in toxic
relationship after toxic relationship
it's something you have to look inside
you chose the partner like i don't like
everyone's getting away from this you
are allowed to get ma you're allowed to
choose who the kid like who the father
of your kid is so after complaining that
he's a deadbeat is waste of time for my
ears because you chose him
you chose him it's like saying art like
if i was if say for example men were the
ones that have kids
would you like it if every time we have
casual sex you had the the chance of
getting pregnant and you had no
say on whether or not
your your kid is brought into the world
whether or not your situation is all
right whether or not you're drunk and
just having casual sex whether or not
it's like you have no control then isn't
that on you to choose who you sleep with
but that's the same way for women
because you you right so if you but the
problem is women are incentivized to
make bad decisions
so women women are literally paid out so
if they if they break up a family they
get child support correct and if they if
they catch a kid by a rich enough guy
they get paid out
and so women are literally paid to make
bad decisions in the uk you can
i remember when i was young there were
girls that got pregnant they could get a
house
do you know what i mean there were girls
that got pregnant they could get money
because you get money you get a free
house you get free money every every
week
and as long as the man is not within the
household you're good so like you said
they're incentivized to make these
decisions
and say okay cool well i don't need a
man around fine i've just got me and my
child but isn't that also a system thing
as well
yeah because that happened right in the
what late 70s 80s early 80s that's when
it all kind of started
yeah no it's i think it's a rotten
system because i don't understand why
you're entitled to a man's money
it's a rotten system because we we make
it like i like i i hate
i hate when women say that bro um
society
the system it's like we are that people
so if we want it to be a different way
it would be a different way but we don't
want it to be a different way because
women are comfortable with the way it is
as it is
i'm telling you they're absolutely
comfortable with they're winning right
now
yeah and it's not it's not oh sir the
world face that you've got to realize
was created to stop women from being
cast out because you know in the
victorian times
if you had a bastard charge you'd be a
destitute on the street your church
would have to take women in so we we men
created the system to make sure women go
into poverty right but what has been
happening now has been abused but was
that before after feminism before before
right
so now we've set the rules when when did
that happen the 1870s okay that's around
the same time no but in the sense of
this if okay
before the rules of women having the
right to be equal it wasn't like men
were like oh you're just a slave in my
room no we said there's certain things
that are for women and certain things
are for men benefits and disadvantages
women didn't have to fight in wars right
exactly they didn't have to do hard jobs
didn't have to climb chimneys and do
nothing they like okay so
you're locked in the house okay your guy
is locked in a factory he's locked in a
pit like they say oh you know it's like
oh dude they locked us up the guy was he
didn't have minimum wage he didn't have
like he didn't have no safety measures
he was working trying to pay for his
family like way we how we fantasize how
back in the day was like we lived there
like we just came from the revolution
it's like no none of us lived there so
when you say society was this way it's
like no no that's how this is how it is
now this is how we want it to be
yeah
there's too many feminists and too many
male feminists you know i also want to
ask i want to ask um the guys here and
the one mother we have right um so
you've already got a child
and
you're you've got someone new
what obligation
does the new man have now to your child
from another
man
would you like like what like does he
take on all of the responsibility as a
father or is there some kind of halfway
dad situation going on
does that make sense because a lot of
women
have
expect a man for instance there was a
viral video this week you know a couple
of days ago where this woman
was she had a father of her child she
had three other children and he came to
bring his child every day lunch and then
she was like oh i've got three other
kids and he's like those ain't my kids
i've got one with you i don't have an
obligation to look after your children
so i'm just like do women who already
have children think that their new man
or another man has the obligation to
look after the children that aren't his
i think it depends on if you're dating
or if you're or if you're taking things
serious i think it depends if you're
dating they don't need to see your child
you're just you know dating and doing
your thing but if you are building with
you you're moving on and you're building
with that person you're gonna you know
get engaged get married have children
and stuff it that kind of comes with
that kind of you you kind of see how
they build their own relationship as
well i feel i feel like you do group
stuff you go out to eat you do whatever
you need to do you know and you see if
that when you're doing introducing after
six months or after a year you see if
your child how they are with that person
you need to see if they if they've got
that relationship you can't force you
can't force it
is he allowed to discipline your child
um
it depends on that situation this is the
thing because because
yeah
i was in a relationship for like 10
years right and when i was in that
relationship i was with a woman who
already had a child
we had a child together but what was
very um
very apparent to me within that
relationship was that i was not allowed
to discipline this child the way i could
discipline my own child right because
the child still had the father in their
life the father would have something to
say about it if i disciplined the child
in a certain way and so
i
there's a lot of men out here saying
that they wouldn't get with a woman a
lot of men saying they wouldn't get with
a woman who already has a child because
you get a lot of the benefits
sorry you don't get all of the benefits
of being a father
right but you have the responsibility as
a father so it's like what is the
incentive for men
to actually get with women who actually
already have children when you know that
at some point in time you are going to
be reminded that that child ain't yours
i'm going to be controversial and say i
think the father should
look after the kid
they're better off statistically yeah
kids are better off after the age of
like eight with their fathers over their
mothers especially even financially like
single fathers tend to be better with
money than single mothers oh wait no i'm
talking about my i i think the step dad
should look after the
the step kid oh the steps out okay
the reason why i say this is because
you're picking the woman
you know she's got a kid already so you
you should assume that you're gonna have
to look after her kid even though she
might not want you to that's it's like
you're picking the woman not the child
no but you know she's got a child so
you're picking the woman and the child
if it's not just to marry her yeah like
it's like you're
she's not going to step she's not going
to like um put the kid up for adoption
like just like no you know they're
coming as a pair so you got to prepare
yourself already to be like you know
what i might not be able to discipline
him the way that i want to i'm sorry i
know i'm gonna have to pay for his this
i'm gonna have to pay for that i'm gonna
have to pay for that i know i'm gonna
have to get this in my air about how you
talking to him please talk to me instead
of talking to the kid and i know you're
gonna get that but i think i think that
um stepdads should be allowed to
discipline the kids because yeah because
like that it's what he's signing up for
if he's gonna take on the responsibility
he should get
it but might as well allow you to do it
though yeah
that's not your child that's my child
i'll discipline the child yeah nine
times out of ten that's what mothers
will do
is there disagreed though the door's
there no i think
if it's not natural it's not organic you
can't fool someone into obligation if
you do that it builds resentment and
that's like coercive control that's like
mental abuse and women complain about
that all the time and what i notice as
well with the women i know that's like
that they're um usually hypocritical
it's double standards they they can do
that kind of pair and said oh well he's
not my child if the father has one
already but if we do that it's a big
problem
this is where this is what i just
disagree with yeah that's what but
that's why men like oftentimes don't get
involved with single moms because it's
just it's too confusing for them i'm
allowed to do this but not that and i'm
taking on the responsibility but i don't
get any of the authority
and that's why a lot of times they come
out and say it's a bad deal and you know
what that does to children
children even if you've got like two
children one's yours and one's not yours
that other child sees that that child
gets treated differently right and so
that child one of the children know that
if they're left with stepdad they can
probably get away with a little bit more
than they could if it was actual dead do
you know what i mean and so they'll push
the boundaries listen up trust me i've
been there yeah i've been there like
they will push the boundaries there
because they know you can't discipline
me like my mom can disagree or my dad
can discipline me
you say that you say that in my
experience obviously i'm not saying this
for everybody but in my experience my
first mother
herodis favored me
at one point he drew me in place of his
dad in his primary school book and all
because i gave him routine and structure
i wasn't too pally pally with him i said
look this is the boundaries you're
stressing out your mother you've got a
certain bedtime you have to go to bed
you said you need to help her out
because i said a lot of the time she's
running around and you're capable of he
could die in his clothes he's good at
folding so i said you need to give him a
bit more responsibility and what i found
amazing at the time i thought he
despised me but he actually started we
started to get really get on and in a
second
i think because he's dead one actually
around
he favored me as well so that that
middle one actually handed me better
than my own son but you know that's what
a lot of people see that they will see
that and they'll say that as a bad thing
not knowing that you're actually helping
the you
so to be fair he's mother she actually
liked it she encouraged it which i found
was a bit peculiar so she is
women that don't want their partner to
discipline the kid
so like even when he's like being a man
in the house and being like
pick up that and whatever like she might
not like it but he might like it like
when i grew up with a step dad my mom
wouldn't know like certain times like
you know what i mean i'd be like raw
like now i'm looking back i'm like
this man is amazing bro like do you know
what i mean like he took me on as a step
son
and treated me like all his other
children
and did you push the boundaries of him
knowing that was you was your actual
biological dad around
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was a bit of a
rich dad poor dad like
so basically i was brought up in
trinidad and england and trinidad than
england right my dad was here my stepdad
was in trinidad right with my mom
and
he was muslim
so i was on the
militant
is style you know i'm saying without
without the terrorism part but you know
what i'm trying to say like five times a
day like ramadan everything ready but
i'm saying when i look back at that now
that was discipline
do you know what i mean i wouldn't see
as that i would be like right this
prayer is so annoying like who do you
think he is my dad do you think my dad
do you think times have changed now
though
like do you think times have changed
like children do you think children show
step
fathers and mothers
adults in general the same respect that
they did when you were growing up it
depends on who's the parent yeah it
depends and the character of the child
as well yeah
depending on the parent bro it's just
statistically now it's a lot of single
parents so it's the it's skewed because
at the end of the day
we we tell men avoid single mothers
yeah even though some men i i don't say
that i say i i don't tell them to avoid
to come up as i say up to a certain age
a man should build for himself and if
he's going to get with a woman it should
be a single woman with no women no
children i feel like people with kids
should just date each other like that's
yeah and that's also an option but i'm
saying if you get once you get to a
certain age generally
women are going to have one or two
children if you get like past the age of
30 and looking for a woman she's
probably gonna have a child or two so
you're gonna have to decide what you're
gonna do but below the age of 30 i don't
think any man should be getting with a
woman with children you say that but i
always find i'm about 27 28 if they
don't have a child already or at least
being in a serious relationship i start
thinking are they weirdos
by what age 27 28 if i haven't had a
long-term relationship or they have an
editing children i think what's wrong
with them
so yeah about the scooter
in this society now really and truly i
personally believe you don't really know
yourself until you're about
late twenties
statistically 50 of women over 30 are
single and childless
and um but that kind of goes into
another stat which is like one out of
three women making over forty seven
thousand dollars per year has had an
abortion so there's a good chance
that maybe they were pregnant at one
point but what do you say that's a
cultural thing because in the uk my
sphere of influence
i've seen most women
have children already you so i mean so
before the age of 30 mostly women
maybe run in different circles
that jamaican circle way
maybe
so are you saying um
so if women in your circle if you think
women before the age of 30 are having
children right
um
and there is men the same age do you do
you advise those men to get with women
with children
in your 20s no i wouldn't otherwise well
but it's also the problem is it's a
mating strategy so what happens a lot of
times is like women have different
things that they look for in a guy and
one of them is good genes so a lot of
times a girl will get pregnant by the
guy with the good genes and then find a
provider to take care of him later
and um if you're if you're the provider
she might not have genuine desire for
you and actually be attracted to you
because she's looking for you to take
care of and that's a risk where a lot of
guys it'll be good until they get
married and they're in a sexless
marriage
but what attracts you to amanda like
well there's there's a couple different
mating strategies that women look for so
like one um is resources when it comes
to like money and um
resources as in he'll stick around and
invest in the child so like girls can
kind of feel like what guy is more of
like a father one is gene so that's
things like height
facial symmetry
strength that sort of thing another one
is legacy it will he embarrass the
family um another one is
i always forget the fifth i put in the
chat what the fifth one is
but yeah there's just different mating
strategies that girls but like in
language terms there's out and i hate
these terms but
shout out rolo okay alpha alpha alpha
fox beta bucks and there's the guy
that's like the girl's super attracted
to and she like sleeps with super soon
and there's there's the
guy that she makes weight and she wants
to take care of her
yeah cool and like girls will look for
both but like a guy with both is rare
yeah and he'll probably cheat on you
because he's rare
and then but the thing is like and we've
spoken about this so many times like
women generally want the same type of
men
you know what i mean and so the reason
why you get baby mamas nowadays fighting
over the same guy is because those guys
are breeding with all of the women
right that's why all the baby moms are
fighting over this one guy this one
guy's got three four women pregnant so
he's got he's got women
those women know exactly what it's like
yeah they know exactly what it's like
and they choose to breathe because he
has those traits and that's the thing
like a lot of girls are sleeping with
ben that aren't fathers
and they and
they're sleeping with men that aren't
fathers like they're not sorry they're
not husbands i should say a better
better term um and they know they're not
husbands and they're sleeping with them
and then they get pregnant by them and
then you know they're shocked when he's
not a husband no but you said get
pregnant she chose to get yes you know i
agree i agree you're right that bad word
right so now we're getting to it now so
now we're getting to it you know that
guy
doesn't want you like how you want him
you trap him
to have your child
and you you try to lock him down
not knowing that you trapping him is not
going to lock him down
you think by you having a baby with him
it stops other girls from having a baby
with him but they just see and see as i
want to have a baby with him as well
it's pre-selection so like biologically
women are predispositioned to i mean not
personally i'm i'm i don't do the whole
kids thing but but
but in general like like um
not me and i don't need that but
but but like genetically we are
biologically predispositioned to like
men that other women want so if another
women woman gave him a baby it signals
to us that he can take care of us too
right of course yeah my dad just told me
don't you so are you a virgin
no i'm not a virgin so would you mean
you don't do the baby thing then i don't
i don't want to date a guy with kids
oh i thought you meant you have a baby
no i don't have a kid
why not would you wait
pearl hasn't got any children yeah no no
children you don't want any children no
i want a lot of kids that's what i'm
trying to say i'm saying i don't date
guys with children
yeah that's not because she wants to
build her own yeah because i just feel
like like that's something that i really
want
like me
i i really want me and my husband to be
you like black men paul
hey hey what's going on here no no i'm
just saying basically i saw on another
podcast okay you're out of the running
you've got a couple kids no no i'm
saying i saw it on a podcast
guys i'm saying you're disqualified
you're disqualifying a lot of but not in
the us fifty percent of black men are
single and childless and in the middle
class yeah but why would i why would i
pick the ones with kids because like no
because he's had a kid before so he
might know how to look after the kids
better but
i don't know he's selling himself right
now
you got kids as well maybe i'm telling
you that you're too got the internet
baby
i've just it's been really important to
me to have like a stable family unit and
that's just something that's really
important to me two parents in the home
i don't want baby mama drama i don't
want any of that i just want two parents
in the home we both have the first kid
together and i don't think it's really
smart to advise girls to go after guys
with kids i think that's like a lot of
the problems we're seeing so do you want
to get married before you have a kid
yeah that's what that's the way to do it
yeah that's what that's the way to do it
like honestly if you get married first
a man feels more obliged to stay with
the woman
i don't i don't know why you think it's
the other way around like not the other
way around as well
bro listen are you going to get down on
your on is she going to get down on her
knee are you going to get down on your
knee
you're getting down on your knee so that
means you've already committed to what
you're going to do right yeah but don't
you think that's because they're
frightening divorce and they think oh
well you know she's going to take her
assets
yeah so i mean it's like it's pretty
expensive to get a prenup you got 10k
laying around i mean if you're gonna
risk half your wealth going then i
should have 10k laying around if i'm
going to have a white dress and a ring
i'm saying that's the reason a lot of
guys don't do it as it is expensive um
and i just know this because i have a
couple friends that have gone through
the process and they just like the the
cost didn't
make sense to them is that what you're
going to tell your potential husband
what i mean personally personally um
like i i want to prenup like on my end
obviously you know himself i said be
clinical though yeah clinton pearl is
protecting her assets yeah
i'll have a prenup but the thing is i i
just don't think it's wise to advise
i think people with kids should just
date each other you guys can do it do
you see what do you see why now men
wanted to have pre
it's so funny how when women start to
make money now they start to understand
oh this is why you wanted to preach
that's the thing i've always said i
would sign a prenup yeah i've always
said that not you you're you're you're
you're you're with us
but i don't i don't really understand
why girls marriage is not about romance
that's one of the major things that
people don't understand marriage is a
contract between two people to do
something it's not generally about
romance in
before it became this i would romance
this fantasy this fantasy it was about
the coming together of two families
right for a specific reason
right and the two people would marry and
they would basically they would
they would become a conglomerate now do
you know what i mean it's not
it's not about it's not about love and
that's that's what i think people get
wrong and and because when you think
about you're going to be with someone
let's say i get married you know let's
say let's say we get married at 30 right
well me and you
let's say we get let's say
um me and somebody get married at 30.
i'm gonna live to probably be 80 90.
that's 50 60 years like are you really
going to love them all 50 60 years like
there are times when my parents didn't
get along but i'm glad that they stayed
together because
i would hate to do two christmases and i
would hate to like have that all split
up
love is not based on just feeling it's
principle it's a choice it's a choice
it's a verb suffering as long as that's
part of it it makes it easy it's like
having medicine that's got sugar in it
some of it is bitter but the sweet one
is easier to go down is
emotions are fickle love is a commitment
it's not just about the feeling so when
you're gonna get married it's love not a
feeling yeah it's part that's part of it
that's part of it but that's only a
small part of it it's a combination of
things it's like it's a paradox are you
saying this duty yeah that's part of it
too yeah but obviously the you have the
feeling duty principle long suffering
sacrifice these are all parts of it but
people only want to take the parts that
they like that's the problem i need to
ask you doesn't mean the parents didn't
love each other because they had
arguments yeah no i know that's just
that's what i'm saying but i saw a lot
of like i had friends parents that also
argued growing up
and they ended up getting a divorce and
i see them like 10 20 years down the
line and they regret it
because it was it would have been better
for the kids and then like i mean you
put
um i just looked up this stat but a kid
is 10 times more likely to be a victim
of sexual sexually abused than children
that live with both biological parents
because if you're bringing in like
random yeah you just never know
yeah that's one of the reasons why i got
rid of my first and mother
imagine stuff like that where would you
be what what that's what i got with my
first son's mother because of things
like that what you're talking about
what bringing different men in
yeah who was gonna say look you've had
two children already
and this year alone they've seen three
other men
i said this is not the kind of
person i would sit down with i don't
envision a future of you right yes i
mean this is a casual thing and then
you're trying to force commitment i said
i can rebuild i said do you think she
was looking for a step back for the
children yeah of course of course well
as soon as she saw that um i'd done a
bit of writing i worked and i had my
even shared housing and i just drove a
golf mark free old old jalopy but she
saw the bases like how long ago was this
golf mark three yeah yeah 2005 oh i was
going to say
yeah so they were carrying on she's
thinking oh well you know his parents
are married still so maybe and that she
said to be fair i told her which i was
silly i told her that yeah the person i
have children i want to stay down with
so who told me to say that within a few
weeks of sleeping with her so mean how
long did it take for her to get pregnant
six weeks six weeks
pre-meditated yeah cool it sounds like
my second baby one's broken what she's
used to tell me that it takes two to ten
dollars
how many mums have you got i've got two
kids bro two baby moms
what are you what are you doing
well the first one was
i was in a relationship with a girl
okay and
we had the kid
and
she left me
the second one i didn't even want do you
like
in fact her mom told her to get rid of
her other like problem before
[Music]
her other problem what do you mean she
took
her mum told her to get rid of her
problem before that she had with another
guy
when i came her mom told her no keep
that one that one
[Laughter]
was either it was either kid planned
uh no did you did you take any
precautions
yeah of course okay what like you're
wearing condoms
[Laughter]
for me to have two kids i did good in
life you got me i did i was oh i don't
know i don't know
i did good in life you know i mean
you sound like you kind of got you kind
of like just fell into situations bro
that's what it sounds like it's like i'm
here now like like one could be a
mistake but two two yeah the first one
wasn't i don't think it was really a
mistake i was in a relationship for a
little while
and when the child came i was
not didn't want it or i didn't want it
it was just like okay say about it i
mean like
all right i'm not going to tell her to
get rid of it that's my first shoot my
second you i'm already like bro i
already got one already like loudest no
no we're not even going there do you
know what i mean and i'll tell you like
there's deeper stories to how
like my second daughter as beautiful as
she is on earth like why she's here but
that one was pressure that second one do
you think you struggled with
responsibility because i know it's a lot
of us are like the struggle with the day
in day out you know having to provide
look after the emotional needs i mean i
mean like i i genuinely think it's it's
mostly on the girl if you get pregnant
because
i mean we have so many forms of birth
control that men don't have the access
to but like two
yeah
that's all right now bro
oh yeah i mean
it's not readily available at this point
so on her side if she wants to have the
baby then there's nothing stopping her
how is your how is your relationship
with these two women is it a good
relationship what now
yeah i have no i have to make it good
now would you mean you have to make it
good in terms of what i was saying
before in terms of like when the dad has
to know that i have to sacrifice
um my like um
sanity and
well-being and feeling nice and feeling
good to accommodate their
like emotional
needs needs if you go i mean like i'm
trying to say in the most like raw way
as well ma'am wanted to say delusions
that's what he wanted to say like you
know i mean like i have to be i have to
be like oh take a lot of stuff
in order for it to work and be cordial
so i was having this conversation
yesterday right um
we're men right and as men
we
we take we don't take well to violations
right so if i violated you i violated
you it could end in a physical
altercation
you go i'm saying
mothers of children
repeatedly violate yeah the fathers of
their children
and there's and as a man you've got to
take it you've got to find a way in
which to get violated a lot of the time
right and just roll with it and next
week
you're talking about this child's school
uniform yeah as if last week never
happened and you never got violated by
this individual last week and and i said
that is a lot on a lot of men's mental
health when it comes to um having the
wrong
baby mother because if i because i'm now
looking at you like i literally want to
argue with you have some kind of autism
but i can't because there's a child
involved and i'm looking at you and i'm
saying
and you're like all right so next week
someone says go into school and and
you're like
did last week not happen like did did
you not like do you not remember what
you said or what you done i had the
therapy for that i said just take
another woman decides to get over there
yeah that's right
i know it's a lot of people when they
are monogamous and they're putting up
with disrespect
it's because they got not outlets no
viruses i should indulge in minds if
they've done that oh i would disappear
because i had my own place where my
first time obviously oh look don't talk
to my he's not your child i said all
right i'm gonna go back to you know the
man cave oh why are you going to do that
for us yeah i don't have to bother with
this he said you got two children two
different men you really think that me
and your size
i said that i'm above you in this thing
i said and i'm nicer than you so i said
if you do that i'll just get someone
else and so that's how i used to
regularly wait for one second you
reminded me something yeah
you see the angerness that the anger
that's what's like
like they're allowed to take out the
anger on you using the kid
yes they're allowed to take out the i
you have to come see your kid if they
just want to see you they don't you they
don't want you to see the kid they want
to see you because they they might they
might have feelings for you they want to
see you but so come and see your kid you
know what it is they play certain games
they do certain things that like they
trap you in certain positions
and they know that having a kid is like
the main tool to do that because the
government backs them up on this yes
there's way around that though because
she used to do that try to play games
with you know the
child support agent cms now
and i used to say look in my left hand
is benefit fraud my right-handed social
services which one do you want that's
the similar direct-down
tonight there's no psychological gains
because i see my mother and that
together for years see there's no games
that you can try and follow with me and
if you if you you try to restrict access
to that go and have more children and
marginalize you she used to he's the
regulator until i went to court to get
him full time
so i have a question for the panel um
when do you so since we talked a little
bit about earlier about what i thought
was a good reason to break up a home
what do you guys think is a good reason
i'm just going around
yeah mental abuse physical abuse
um
not really adultery yeah i say mental
physical abuse mental and physical abuse
okay what about you yeah i think um yeah
dv
um any sort of abuse um
and i do think repeated adultery yeah
repeated adultery okay about the same
abuse um
anything that leaks into the child's
life
and therefore affects the child
yeah it's good enough reason for you to
leave
mine is solely mental abuse but only
because i've seen the impacts it's had
on people around me
and
how it affects not only the child but
their interactions with other people
and potentially
the difficulties that they face finding
a new person as well so definitely
mental abuse
yeah i would say death
death yeah till death do us
isn't that what we signed like isn't
that what we said when we was up there
like do you know what i mean it's like
okay so
my it's very easy for men to be like you
physically i mean you mentally abuse me
like he mentally abused me like women
are the king of games bro from the
minute from the minute we started this
relationship he was mentally abusing me
so now now now we're even um what type
of girls do you deal with this is why
i'm just no you've got bad experiences
don't get me wrong i'm the most
empathetic to men's issues i'm so
empathetic i'm on your side
but like sometimes like i i do think
there's some accountability on the guys
for the women that you pick i love black
women
what did you say i love black women
okay
in and around black women pearls
like with two different
kettles of fish
yeah highly likely they're coming from a
single parent household themselves
you're coming from a double parent
household who stayed together who's
shown the successful work
you're different like you're
like sometimes i look at you and think
how
is she is she a female like do you know
what i mean i think are you a female
like because
and in england or america or in the west
because that is just not a normal
mindset to have the one that you have
the one that i'm talking about in terms
of the girls that's the normal mindset
i'm the b-o-s-s you can't tell me
nothing you pay the rent you go on the
first date you still can't tell me
nothing in this yard
it's super it's super common but i'm
telling you i know a good amount of
girls that don't have that mindset
and i'm saying like there has to be i
i'm with it like i i understand the
struggles you guys go through but there
has to be some accountability right for
the men too when it comes to the type of
girls you choose to deal with
because i'm a big believer like as a
girl
every situation i've been is my own damn
fault like i've been cheated on before
and that was my own fault because i
picked him like my fault so i just think
it really is because if i if i that's
who i chose it's my fault and i'm just a
big believer in like the situations you
choose to put yourself in if you got two
children for two quote-unquote crazy
baby mamas
okay fine they're not crazy but if
you've got two children for
two women and it's not going the way
that you want it to go
um then i said and like pearl said
maybe look at the women you're choosing
bro it's not that it's not that it's not
going the way i want it to go i am
accommodating them they're not
accommodating me i'm accommodating them
would you what is what does that mean
what do you mean
from the okay
my seeds
is like your egg is irrelevant without
my seeds so we are we are making the kid
together it's not your it's not your
baby
yes right but a lot of women come with
that mentality of it's my baby and it's
true you are the father of my baby
that's because they have the leverage
yeah in the court like the courts back
them on this yeah yeah but i mean in
terms of like the attitude so it's like
it's i'm it's my baby but you're the
father what i'm saying like you could
you could pick girls that don't have
this attitude
no yeah we always say
no no but i'm just i'm just being honest
like again like it's twice right you
have two like two baby moms with two
different kids that's two families that
aren't going to be together yeah and and
like it has to say something about your
ability to pick no
because
because i'll tell you why
encounter how many how many friends how
many women leave amer um um
relationships again what was this this
is 70 to 80 oh my gosh right no i'm not
so i'm not leaving the relationship
she's leaving the relationship
were you in a relationship yes second
girl no
i don't even want to go into why as to
okay
but again
first one i i'll give to you right first
like okay you had nothing to do with it
but you you it's like what what is the
best predictor of future behavior past
behavior
what the second one was the essay
there we go so i did not
i didn't agree to to have
intercourse with her
ah
what happened she took your spam no i
was i was drunk and i was sleeping and i
woke up with her on top okay jesus yeah
but you still got a
finish
yeah
that's why i take responsibility for it
but at the end of the day
you tell her to stop
hell no
no listen no
okay you're drunk you're drunk and
you're sleeping and you wake up with me
in you
wait wait wait are we just like no no no
no we're not dating okay so bro you got
an erection while you were not dating
have we hooked up before
no
you'd never hooked up with her no so the
first time you met this girl you were
drunk and then you she found herself on
top of you
and then pregnant and then you're
pregnant same time pretty much
stop the cap
no rule rubber rule stuff like i find it
i find it very embarrassing when you
woke up and then when you woke up and
she was on top of you you did not stop
you didn't say oh my god what you're
doing get off me you said actually keep
going and i'm gonna go till i finish no
i i said i was drunk
so i'm
okay
yeah exactly but you're already on me
and it's i'm not gonna lie it's feeling
good you know what i'm trying to say but
it's now after i'm click like you know
i'm trying to say i'm clicking in now
wait hold on a minute hold on hold on
like how did you like wait what
and it's like after but me as like so
you look great
did you
did you did you tell the police
no of course no no
very well could have happened like that
but it's just the story sounding like
kind of funny like it sounds like it
sounds like like
amazing
it'd be tough for you to claim that that
happened purely because when
you had the opportunity to stop yeah you
did not
yeah but bro if i if it was my choice i
would have put a condom on are you not
listening like
i'm not saying i'm not saying you it
wasn't your choice but i'm saying i'm
like i'm thinking of the equivalent
right if a guy i was seeing like that
happened to me right and i woke up and
then i was like oh yeah let's keep going
and then we finished then i say after oh
i was grape like i think a lot of people
would kind of look at me funny right you
know what i'm saying like if i if i got
on top and started riding right like
like and then people be like
how can you say you were graped if you
finished it that's why i didn't answer
when you said was i great because i like
okay i was vying you said essay though i
was right that's what i think it was it
was uh it was essay and it was it wasn't
great it was essay
but you enjoyed it
like that i mean okay
wait hold on you're drunk and i have sex
with you yeah just because you enjoy it
does that mean that you agree to it well
does she wake up and say stop like get
off me or does she say oh [ __ ] like and
then start writing like there's two
different
there's two different no you like you
like you lost him because if i if a girl
says she's drunk yeah and i had and i
had intercourse with her while she was
sleeping that's automatic me cancelled
bro why are you not even trying to make
excuses for the guy bro like i don't
care like if she did that to me like if
i'm drunk enough to if you said stop and
you would like oh [ __ ] like what are you
doing like i didn't say what you're
doing i didn't say stop i'm like what
are you doing
and then what what do you mean brother
no it's like i'm drunk and you're on me
riding like
but i would keep it the same with a girl
like i would keep it the same with a
girl if she was seeing a dude and she
was in a situation when they're in bed
together so i'm assuming there's some
history and she wakes up and he he's in
her and if she says what the like get
off of me that's one thing but if if she
finishes like then
how am i going to say that's not
consensual yeah yeah but then there's no
one witnessing it so they can easily
turn that around if they regret
afterwards that's the thing that women
do yeah i mean don't give me there's a
lot of issues in the justice system like
that definitely favor
women but i'm saying i'm keeping a stack
with you i would keep it the same a man
or a woman
so you're saying
that if i went
took like we had like drinks or whatever
we're chilling and we go back to mine
and you fall to sleep
and you wake up with me on top of you
pearl
you're like your first fool as a woman
anyway is like raw what are you doing
right but you're talking about a man now
sarah you kind of bro i'm not saying she
was butters i didn't say she was not
were you planning to do it
no otherwise i was planning to have sex
with her but not without a condom on
right okay do you understand what i'm
trying to say like yeah she's nice and
whatever but i wanted to have sex with a
condom on because of my previous
reactions though you can send it because
you didn't tell it to stop exactly
so now i'm drunk now
if i was in my head level-headed i would
have said get off because when i when i
did come around to my head i'm like what
the hell like what do you do we tell
women the same thing right we say listen
if you
if you go back to a guy's place right
and your intention is to have sex right
and
it happens and then after the fact now
you're saying all of these things people
speculate as to what really happened in
that
is that really happened why'd you go
back to his place like what were you
doing on the bed with him what if he
didn't want to do it why are you that we
speculate and that's all we're doing
with you this is because it just sounds
a little bit sketchy bro that's all no i
it's not sketchy bro she i i didn't mind
having sex with her but you just didn't
want to do it with a condom right now
you could have stopped her before it was
time to finish no you see this is this
is this is the gray area now so now this
is the gray area i'm drunk i can't i'm
not in control
i'm not in control just like a woman say
i'm not in control i'm not in control
because i'm not in my right state of
mind
like i say the same thing right i say if
i get drunk and rob a store i'm still
liable for robbing that store if i get
drunk and have sex like i'm not going to
put that on the guy
personally i know some girls do but this
is just i'm just keeping it drinking
asleep how long between you when did you
get it up yeah how long between you
waking up
realizing oh [ __ ] she's on me
to you finishing not very long
oh so it was oh my god
oh my god well not really it was it was
like i would say give it 20 30 seconds
bro i'm not in my right state of mind
that i'm not like pre i don't like
coming for
but if i'm not prepared if i'm not in my
like frame to hold it out like and i'm
drunk i'm not like you know what i'm
gonna say bro i'm even back the day
after i'm like did that even happen bro
you know you don't understand how drunk
i was bro like i don't like
okay i'm not saying you're lying i'm not
gonna say you're lying i just sound
sketchy that's okay okay i'm gonna take
a second to read super chats and if we
wanna do the subs and i ish
okay so um
thank you guys for the super chat as you
guys know we are trying to get ish a
camera what does ish look like you guys
want to find out send a super chat
people and guys it's really important
now because we're at the end of the
month so the way youtube works is you
get paid month by month so at the end of
next month hopefully we can get ish a
camera
if we get enough super chats this month
so um let me start from the top
lazy artist he's capping so hard right
now just say you aft up bro
stfu ffs the common
denominator to all of your drama is you
um kyle can two parent households still
struggle life would be much easier with
multiple women in the household you save
a lot of money and heartache when you
teach your own kids instead of playing
games
amuro ray 214
single dads and single moms are not the
same the uk economist muslim women seem
to seek out good husbands early on they
don't waste time i think muslims are
showing the rest of us how it should be
done stf uffs the plural of anecdote is
not data
charles serdak it depends as a
or feminism a woman will decide if she's
a feminist or traditional only once the
situation forces her to choose
then she will do whatever is best for
her in the moment crazy legs bear um
thank you for the super chat jc
responsibility without authority is
slavery freedom's journal fathers
picking a mate is beneficial to women
constant complaining about the men they
pick use a father filter jack nolf uh
fifty dollar super chat
sound the alarm if men choose to opt out
of financial responsibility of paternity
by default they lose all authority to
protect
sons from mothers who can legally alter
that into daughters surgically larry ray
um kevin samuel said it best it's not
about love it's about respect and it's
about duty pearl every time you bring up
the point the young lady in black says
but greg see i was embarrassed by my
parents fighting when i was a kid
because my neighbors could hear i'm
happy they stayed together now 30 years
later zach krueger the song ill mind of
hopspin 9 plays out how most
relationships seem to play out nowadays
give it a listen to see what i mean the
uk economist questioned why are kids
awarded to the parent who may be
unemployed why not give the employed
parents such as the father custody chris
cruz would you guys rather talk about
things like low iq and single motherhood
or how high iq for women makes them less
likely to find a partner but not men
christopher cerdec modern marriage is
nothing but hostage taking the kids are
held from the dad and he says
and he gets to pay the mothers ransom
just say no brothers benjamin wheeler
what changes in the u.s or uk laws can
be made re-child rearing between
divorced parents if the laws favor the
mothers what equitable changes can be
made
let me refresh it real quick i think
that's all the super chats
um
okay wait wait there we go
um another ko ken the grown man is alone
and drunk with a woman saying he's
surprised sex-handed sex he's alone and
drunk with a woman saying he's surprised
the sex happened stop making excuses and
grow up
okay um thank you for the super chats
guys again they are going towards
getting issue camera while you're at it
sign up for our memberships um to get
exclusive behind-the-scenes content we
did a vlog this week ish lost the bet
and he had to buy me and just dinner um
so if you guys want to see what happened
send money all right sign up for our
memberships that's under the ten dollar
tier lovely
um we just got some subs
guys uh introduce yourselves please my
name is charlie um
i am 33 i'm a dad of one
i'm here to talk about this topic all
right
uh my name is jesse praise um i'm 24
years old i work for hedge fund they
make videos on tick tock and youtube
lovely i've got a question
um thank you guys for joining us
do you i'll ask the ladies first i get
to the men do you think
mothers
or fathers are better at raising sick
children by themselves
start here
six or six sorry so do you think that
mother yeah mothers or fathers are
better at raising children by themselves
i would say
like me personally because i'm
i come from a family of two parents
um
everything seems a bit nuclear so
even if my family parents even if my
family have arguments and disagreements
it's good to learn from both
parents you know i would i feel
better being in a nuclear family than
being in a single parent family because
i feel like
um
i wouldn't get the best of both
parents who do you think's a better
parent mother or father statistically
statistically
mothers okay
by you
[Music]
honestly it depends who's willing to
step up to the job i feel like fathers
have a lot to offer um
as well as women and i mean honestly
apart from breastfeeding what can't a
man do that women can
men might be more inclined to provide
but that doesn't mean that they don't
have the emotional capacity or emotional
intelligence to provide for a child like
that same way a mother could provide for
her child you know financially in all
the ways that men typically do
but i gotta say statistically
probably
the mother
as a mother what do you think
um
growing up myself
my situation was um shared parenting so
i went half three four days with my dad
and half of my mum growing up until i
got to about age 11.
um i would say
there was things that i learned when i
was with my dad
and how and then also things that with
my mom so i it's it's in that but at the
same time
um
i would say
statistically mothers
but
not saying that dads cannot raise
children on their own i i think that if
if they were raised by um a two-parent
household themselves they will know
they will know how to do both so but
yeah that's what i would say charlie
you're a single father right um
yeah um
i don't think we'll we'll know until you
get the balance changing i mean like you
said
you get 80
is that right where the single single
family cents will be the kids with the
mothers so
if you balance that out with the 20
of dads that have their kids and they're
better off financially
if you've got a 50 50 ratio which i
don't advocate for i don't like things
like that but if you did have that you
might get a better answer the question
um
i'll give you this a statistics right
pew reports that the median adjusted
annual income for a single dad with two
children
is about forty thousand dollars in
america
compared to 26 000 for a single mom with
two children
so would you say that financially
we say well it does say financially
children are better off with us as with
single father i think i think it
confirms the gender roles actually you
know mothers are there to nurture and to
raise into real children
and men are there to provide or protect
i think that statistic actually goes to
show that that is the natural order of
things because men are more productive
in in the sense of what you've described
those statistics there um
but i'm biased i think i'm a great dad
so i i don't necessarily think that you
can have
um a binary women are better men or
worse i think it just depends on the
person it depends on how you are
guided um how you're raised what your
morals are you know it's it's all those
things i mean i think you need them for
different things like men and women are
needed for different things but the
reason that i think men tend to be
better single parents is because women
are chemically different every day so
over a certain age it's very confusing
for the kid
because one day she's you know
more irritable one day less irritable
where men are more consistent like as i
think most girls can attest the week
before a period where
you just said that women are more like
um
emotionally unstable you would say yeah
so do you think it's the best advice for
her to have the kid
when she's emotionally unstable for like
for her to have the decision
um
i mean she should be married before she
has a kid no we're talking about like
modern day do you think the like it took
like you know how road versus wade like
the new abortion stuff do you think
that a woman during the time when she's
pregnant pregnant when her emotions are
everywhere her hormones are everywhere
do you think she should be able to make
that decision of whether or not she has
the kid or not do you think she's in the
right frame of mind
no i don't believe in abortion
so i think if that's your bad lie in it
what would you say yeah one second what
were we using uh yeah think the better
better parent is um so i don't think
people understand how
important the role of a father is in
when it comes to raising a child yeah
between the ages of you know from birth
to eight
um the child being raised my mother is
fine but then from that point on
especially when you have a son
the father plays such an important role
in that child's life even men don't even
understand how deep it is so
every
17 i think 70 of people
children born into you know
single-parent households
that get towards women so this is a
single mother um
their life is way way worse than you
know if it was in the
um double parent household basically and
even things like
if in a fatherless home a child is
41 of children are
make um sorry
end up making less than the actual than
their father
which pretty much makes like a perpetual
state of
not being wealthy which affects children
a lot
you know
fathers keep
sons out of jail and those of the polls
some people say but it's it's actually
so crazy how important it is yes when
they're young fair enough you know
keeping them on but when they get past a
certain age again especially with sons
you kind of have to stop
leaving them with with their moms
because especially when you're outside
you can't you know you can't really
discipline him as much because he's
stronger than you you know so you need
you need that testosterone to match
so single mothers are four times more
likely
to live below the poverty line
without a father in house
in america according to
census bureau report u.s census bureau
report they're four times more likely to
live below the poverty line so having a
father in the house is essential
for the financial stability of a child
and also the mental stability of a child
well many women are on track to be
homeless now because women um because
we're more emotional we tend to make
more like quick buying decisions i mean
how many girls do you know that are
addicted to like shopping and
i mean i can think of like five off the
top of my head and that's why a lot of
advertising campaigns are directed as
women because we're again we're
chemically different and we're more
likely to be influenced by that stuff
and so we're more likely to make like
quick purchasing decisions
um
but the and women own two-thirds of the
world's debt
so
even though we make ten thousand dollars
or pounds roughly
than men more per year no less
even though we make less money we spend
more and 70 70 to 80 of consumer buying
decisions are made by women so it makes
a lot of sense to me that a lot of women
that are in single their single mother
homes are below the poverty line
okay
wow
can i ask you though charlie right um
how did it get to the point where you
are now a single father
because it's quite rare
yeah i mean
um
to be honest me and my daughter's mother
we were together for a long time um
but when it come to an end it just was
it was it was natural to me to kind of
assume the role of being a full-time
parent i mean
um my lifestyle suited it because i work
in music so most of my work comes in on
the weekends so i have that freedom to
be around during the week when there's
responsibility involved um
but what i would say though is that we
worked very hard to get to a point now
where we both have a big role in our
daughter's life so
there isn't any animosity now there
isn't any tension now there's no drama
now and i think that in the beginning
you have to really meander your way
through that to work out
are you doing what's best for the child
because listening to half of the
conversation um from the other side of
the camera in this debate tonight
there's lots of trivialization i find
with with the raising of children it's
like we've all been blessed well you and
i have been blessed so not all of us us
three have been blessed with children
and i find that some of the arguments
that parents can have
are are so minor in the grand context of
life of raising that child is so minor
no i i agree um
however
i think that um
like i said because the child is
normally with the mother
those
let's say petty arguments
normally come from that side
i had my share at the beginning when we
first broke up we had a few
ding dongs i think that's expected when
you broke up with um
with anyone whether you've got children
or not you have a few ding dongs at the
end
um
i mean i think that
you're right it's rare
but i don't think that makes me um
exceptional some people look at me like
i'm some sort of unicorn sometimes when
i tell my story but it's like it's not
it's not that deep like we had ma we
made a decision to have a child
and we've tried our best to do the best
we can and you know i'm very proud of
the job we've done i think
uh i think a lot of the time um when it
comes to using a child as a pawn
um
[Music]
women know how to tell stories
right and a lot of the time women are
believed
especially when it comes to the family
court system um a woman can say
a man can um
he's quote-unquote abusive he's
quote-unquote narcissistic he's
quote-unquote whatever it is that she
makes up
to i guess alienate the father from that
child she's more likely to be believed
than a father saying oh the reason why i
want to take the child like in in a lot
of cases a woman has to damn near be
caught strangling her child
for that child to be removed from
her do you know what's a crazy story
that i heard in the u.s um
there was a mother that gave her kid up
for adoption even though the father
wanted it
and the father like had no rights in the
court system
because she chose to give it up for
adoption
yeah like father's rights in the court
system as i said yeah i've spoken to so
many different men
um when it comes to the court system and
the family court system specifically in
the uk and the us is so heavily skewed
towards uh
women that you remember i don't know if
you remember in 2004 with fathers for
justice when they scold buckingham
palace right i don't know if you know
the story pearl so over here in 2004
there's a organization called fathers
for justice right and they are their
single fathers or their fathers
separated from their children and they
want justice to try and see their
children they went they got to the point
where they had to they went to
buckingham palace risked their lives
put on a batman suit a spider-man suit
and scaled buckingham palace and put a
banner up saying fathers for justice and
i'm just thinking if men have to get to
the point where they can actually lose
their lives because if you're going it's
like going on the white house lawn
trying to get on the white house you're
gonna get shot do you know what i mean
but if men have to go to that
degree to try and tell the government
look something needs to change here i
have a stat so one study in 2004
confirmed that divorced people have a
higher suicide rates than their married
peers and that divorced men are eight
times more likely to kill themselves
than divorced women's overall correct i
think when fathers are removed from
their children um
people assume that a lot of fathers just
deadbeats they don't care about their
children but a lot of the time it
affects them mentally well and they
could be in financial ruins over it too
yes i mean men men need purpose
right i think that when you have
children and you want to be a good man
children give you purpose
so if a woman is able to remove that
at will even sometimes on a whim
your life can become meaningless right
and
i'm fortunate to have never experienced
that and i hope i never do never have to
go for any legal troubles or anything
like that
but if i did
and i couldn't see my daughter
i wouldn't want to live
and that's the reality that i think
when women play games
they don't take that into account
because they're in that like you said
they're emotional creatures women are
emotional creatures more often than not
and they don't have the rationale to go
actually let's take a step back and look
at this that's not a woman i'm not
generalizing there's some great single
mothers that get on great with their
dads
um but on the whole you hear more
stories about it
and i think that
people are just expected to just look at
men and go oh well he'll get on with it
yeah he's fine he'll get on with it like
he'll be stoic he'll he'll keep his
stiff upper lip and he'll crack on but
it's not really like that for me because
you know when we talk about our emotions
about kids you don't talk to women about
your emotions with your kids you talk to
other dads yes and you don't have that
conversation women don't know how we
really feel yeah they don't
it's it's it's kind of mad when you talk
about your experience with your daughter
and things because i think being a dad
can be i'm not a dad but from what i've
seen before i've um conversations with
other people being a dad can be such a
thankless job
because
when you're
doing things right when you're doing
everything perfect society tells you you
should be doing that right like you're
meant to be that's meant to be what
you're doing when you're not bare
minimum exactly exactly when you're not
perfect
that child is going to end up resenting
you at some point and so it's it's kind
of crazy um seeing you sit here and
saying these things because
you know obviously god forbid your child
ever goes up to despise you or anything
like that but it's such a hard job being
a dad
and you know you seem to be taken on and
you love it so i do love it
i have a question um do you guys think
that women are entitled to child support
yes or no
entitled in what context um so
like do you think that the child child
support should exist basically
um
that's so nuanced the question i mean
should it exist
i think i think i think it is there to
kind of give people that sense of you
have a responsibility when things fall
apart
but
i i don't know i don't i don't know if
it should exist or not because
you know you didn't get paid to have the
kid in the first place
i mean i think if you're if
it's a tricky one i think if you if
you're good and you're a good person and
you want to look after your child you
will look after your child i don't think
for me i think state involvement is with
children is a bit of a no-no yeah it's
not what the guys should do it's like
should the government force men to pay
i don't like the word force i mean i
mean because you don't if you don't pay
child support you go to jail yeah so you
are forced it's like you don't in the uk
you don't go to jail child support in uk
but in america um
i think i think it depends doesn't does
the opposite work in reverse in the
united states that's what you're
referencing so if if you have a man
who's got custody of his child he's the
woman obligated to pay child support in
america
um is she up it's not as common um it
does happen but they're usually
headlines because it's the exception
rather than the rule i don't i don't
believe in child support at all i think
you should get a job
like
in a failing economy it might be hard to
get if i missed the context i thought
child support was forcing the man to
give money to them yeah yeah no it is
and sometimes it's occasionally it's
reverse but i'm saying even in that
context i don't understand why you can't
get a job
as a girl
like because you're a woman i think even
when you've got a job you still have to
pay that i think i know in the uk it
works with with residency so if you if
say you know if a child is five days out
of seven with yeah she gets the the
benefit and it's not just child support
it will be
state child benefit it will be adverse
or credit it will be anything else right
but i think it should just be
automatically 50 50.
like if both parents like not nothing no
dv nothing of that it should just be 50
50 and no child support so i've got a
because it's like double story
um
so when i was raising my son right and
and i
i mean his mother broke up
i was paying
uh her without the government right
involvement so we agreed on a fee every
month and i was paying that every month
and then i had my son half the week and
she had him half the week so i was all
right that's cool for me and um
what happened was is that somebody said
to me
are you are you giving her money every
month and i was like yeah of course for
my son and they were like you're not
entitled to do that you have your son
half the week
and i was at
really
and so i went on the got
gov website
and it stated yeah if two people are
cold
actually co-parenting
no one owes each other money yeah and i
was like oh what am i paying this money
for so when i informed her you know what
no more money
that's when problems began
and that was very interesting i'd like
to hear from the girls what you guys
think about child support
um i feel like it should is
if if you if the father is not
contributing
um and he's not doing it just by you
know because he's supposed to and
looking after his child etc
and
they there is some relationships where
they can't communicate they can't come
to a common ground the child lives with
the mother
more time
i do believe they have to be something
in place um
because again even if the mother is
working again sometimes
due to child care they have they can't
work certain hours they can't do certain
things and i feel like to give that
child a a decent life
you would as a father would want to you
know pay and do what you need to do
whether that's paying for after school
clubs i do think there's other ways of
contributing i don't but i do think cs
child support is very toxic as well at
the same time it can cause problems
but it there needs to be there also it
needs to be something in place for when
relationships or when parents can't come
to
an agreement why
because then the child gets
the child gets left left in a why should
the child suffer basically
you know do you think that incentivizes
women to make poor reproductive choices
because they get bailed out
so even if you pick the the guy that
clearly wasn't a good father
like you still get bailed out because we
should be picking men that
are will stay in the kids lives like you
seem to have a really good relationship
with your yeah i think that but there is
some times where you could go you've
heard stories sometimes people have been
with people they've they've been good
guy break up and they've they just
changed i mean you know and you just but
do we base rules based on the exception
i think most girls that that happens to
they saw the red flags early on and they
just don't listen to anybody yeah like
yeah why are you laughing because it's
true it's true right yeah but i feel
like that it can change
i do feel like the the csa at the moment
has been
it is being used for the wrong reasons
and i also do think
that um it will be better if parents
could come to a you know an agreement i
do believe i don't think money is
everything because well i think that
sometimes hands-on help is more is more
better off to be honest but everyone's
different
okay what do you think
um i don't think the government should
be involved i think if uh two people are
mature enough to have a child they
should also be mature enough to both
provide for the child in whatever means
necessary
but like you said i do think it's
necessary to have something in place for
if one party can't keep up their end of
the deal in looking after the child so i
think it should be harder to
okay what do you think um well i had a
similar um
story to you sarah one of my friends
close friends was in a situation it was
quite fairly recent actually in lockdown
where he couldn't provide um for his
children because he lost his job
and he was paying monthly
a good rate that was discussed before
this encounter
and out of malice his ex was like okay
well i'm going to take it to you know
i'm going to take it to court and
get my
child maintenance increased and that was
very detrimental to his mental health
because this was out of his control no
one knew that the pandemic was going to
occur you know and when you're doing
such
you know when you're providing such duty
for your kids willingly you know despite
all of the the fights and the arguments
and the break that breakouts that have
occurred you're still there for your
child
still trying to um
provide for them and then
something happens and you can't no more
and then they they use the opportunity
because they've got like um the
government backing them up to now
account for um the
the finances just like do you think that
girls would make better reproductive
choices if they knew there were
consequences
yes like if maybe they knew child
support wasn't an option if they got
pregnant
yeah i feel that there would be a lot of
premeditated decisions if i knew that um
you know if i'm gonna go out with a man
and he's he's not gonna be there for me
i'll make sure i'm gonna have my job i'm
gonna make sure i have my house i'm
gonna make sure i'm i'm well equipped
before i get into that make sure you're
on birth control yeah as as well
as well she wasn't gonna mention that
i didn't think i needed to i mean i i
hold myself to a high regard so yeah
sorry um but oh you know
yeah you could oh sorry i could tell if
you were carried on sorry
no no no
no no i'm done but yeah no i just don't
wait before you carry on we've got to
stat over here um if i let my brother
just read that
hold up
this is for you charlie the rise in
single father families is significant by
the office for national statistics whose
family households in the uk and report
for 2019 says since 1999 the total
number of single parent
especially fathers is in the region of
2.4 for 9 million as of 2019 this is
seen as a significant increase on how it
was 20 years ago
that's interesting
why do you think that it's not the
reception
euro you're not the exception it's the
second
highest growth in single-parent
households is single for others
why do you think that is
um
i think it's layered but i think maybe
one of the reasons is
um
people are realizing that women aren't
the best
parent all the time
for the child well i think there was a
time in our history like
during the metoo era where it was almost
like women could do no wrong believe all
women at
any cost
and now that things like amber heard
have come out and other you know crazy
girls that like come to the forefront
because again i always say this if it
happens to celebrity who else does it
happen to right like that's clearly
happened to the average guy if this
could happen to someone you know super
famous with money and power right um so
i think like
that has really
given men more rights than maybe they
had in the past but their system still
is really broken it's still skewed yeah
you know it really is sorry you were
going to say something bro yeah just
when you when it comes to you know
talking about um you know women choosing
who they have sex with speaking to them
when it comes to women choosing to have
sex with you know
again people actually don't understand
how important it is to pick a man based
on
is this man going to be a good father
is this man going to be here because you
know 81 percent of teen team pregnancy
has come from fatherless homes you know
80 of kids on the street
again often fatherless homes
if you're picking a guy who yeah just
looks good and you know guess the juice
is going fair enough like your kids
might look good but
are they going to be actually helping
you know propagate society or are they
going to be a dutchman society a lot of
times you know
the men that women complain about
come from homes single single mother
homes
and it's crazy it sounds bad like i
don't i don't mean to say that single
mums are evil or anything like that but
a lot of the
worst types of men in this world come
from single mother homes because you
need a man there to
sometimes
give a good slap to the son's face when
he's growing up just uh you know just to
humble limit i make you think what am i
doing in my life
what what where am i going where am i
trying to what kind of life am i trying
to lead and so yeah i just think people
need to start thinking about a bit more
when they're picking who to who to go
for
i think unfortunately that bad boy image
that's been sold to so many women that
women are attracted to
um
makes them
as you said gets their juices going but
those quote-unquote bad boys which most
women are attracted to
aren't necessarily going to be a good
father right they're not necessarily
going to be a good father so i think
that bad boy image has been now sold as
what manhood is
so even within like rap songs right
rappers are sold as like the ultimate
alpha male right that's that's what it's
sold as right they're not generally a
lot of them probably couldn't you know
connie do a lot of things but
it's sold like they're the
they're the ultimate alpha male however
those guys
nine times out of ten
aren't
good fathers
do you know i mean they're the type of
guy who you know have sex with women
here and there have a couple of babies
here and there and then just move on do
you know what i mean and i think a lot
of women get sold i said they get sold
that that hyper masculine man
is the one that they can take for
you know
a good stable family man and that's not
the guy that you're gonna tame to make a
stable man it's just not gonna happen
do you guys think women um pick nice
guys or bad boys
oh i feel like um first
first i will say
i think that when they're young under 25
they go for the bad bad boys okay and
then they learn from experience
i'm trying to put it the best yeah yeah
are you talking from experience
no i'm just saying
[Applause]
but yeah i think that's the bad boys
i agree i think bad boys
i would agree but i personally wouldn't
go for a bad boy because i learned from
other people's mistakes
i was going to say that
you said you said you came from a
two-parent home right do you think that
has helped you vet guys better with guys
yeah because you have your dad as like
an example not necessarily because i
speak to my brother i have an older
brother i speak to him about like boy
problems if i ever like
yeah but i wouldn't speak to my dad
about it because where i was i was born
here and my dad's from ghana so they
have like traditional ideologies about
what a relationship should consist of
and what it shouldn't you know i mean so
it's just like it's really hard to
explain that to my father now do you
know what i mean so i just how long have
your parents been married um plus
30 years you don't think it's good to
get an opinion of a guy that's been
married 30 plus years on what to look
for i just feel like i haven't had that
connection with my dad so i'd find it a
little bit awkward to have that
conversation with him whereas with me
and my brother i see my brother more as
the paternal figure because we have such
a vast m age gap
so um yeah but do you know what pearl i
think it would be good to get advice
from people who have been in
relationships for that long if they are
in tune with what is going on in 2022
and a lot and i think a lot of parents
who have been
um
together for a long time are together
because they're from a different era but
isn't it kind of impossible for
that for those two things to be together
you know it's somewhat mutually
exclusive for them to be together that
long and then also be in tune with
what's going on now because they haven't
been in the dating market right now
so yeah exactly
it's it's kind of like i can't be asking
my dad about
advice for what's going on now
when he was dating what 40 years ago
yeah but i think there's just some
wisdom that comes from experiences and
success
like i was actually shocked when i
started asking my dad for like like
dating advice a little bit like he men
are very insightful i think it's good
you talk to your brother too because i
think men just have it they're better at
vetting men than women are a lot of the
time because we can like
i don't know like the red flag
yeah
men know men yeah yeah
man no sorry you're gonna say something
charlie
it was about what you said about um
being in tune with today's dating scene
if you've been married for such a long
time 30 years
i don't think it makes any difference
because the trends are the same
go on
see you ladies admit you'd go for a bad
boy in your early years
i think if i was to ask the elder women
in my family when they were single
before they got married what kind of
member they attracted to before they
settled down they'd probably say the
same thing i can see the trend happening
with
uh like even girls that i've dated
they'll go with a bad boy but that most
of the women that i know that have got
children that are single they're all to
bad boy men
and i find that what you are
i wouldn't i wouldn't sound like no i
wouldn't say i'm a bad boy no i wouldn't
say i'm a bad boy sorry continue
no no i know but i would say that i've
got elements of you know being a bit
direct and being very much like this is
what we need to do to get this stuff
done and i don't mind dismissing a
situation or relationship if it's not
working out and it's beneficial
to the progress of my family
right see i don't necessarily need a
woman to walk into my situation and
think she's going to be a mum there's a
difference between what
i think single men want in relationships
versus what single mothers want from so
your mothers want a step yeah earlier on
you you want that guy to come in and and
look after you because that would be the
natural order of things the man heads
your family whether it be the biological
man to your children or another one the
extra man is what i would call him um
you call him the extra man the extrovert
he's always going to be extra because
he's never he's never going to come
first right he's not the biological dad
the kid knows that the mum knows that
but i find that men especially myself i
speak for myself
i don't expect any woman to walk into my
life and say
i'm i'm expected to be a stepmom and i
make that very clear like i make it very
clear
this is my responsibility
if you want to take part
and it gets to that point and you meet
my child and you want to go there you
can
but it's not an expectation correct and
i think that's where you have the
jadedness that you have from men that
try to avoid single mums
because
there is the expectation whether women
want to want to admit it or not
that they must step up to the mark yeah
and feel the void that the alpha the bad
boy left behind right
but i think also when it comes to men
avoiding single moms
you know i'm 24. right now i'm taking my
prime physically in terms of my own
potential you know there's still time to
go there but
the way i i look at it is why would i
want to
get um go into a family that's already
somewhat built and have to i have to
fill that role when i can you know find
someone who doesn't have a kid build my
own home and again like you were saying
before you know i have certain rights to
that kid in terms of how i discipline
him how i do certain things what he um
their their
routine whereas when it's not my child
fair enough i can love that kid
but the moment of mum doesn't love me
anymore it's done it's finished you're
right so you're right and you have no
rights to the kids after
so like i've talked to um guys that have
raised a kid for like 10 years or five
years and and they fall in love with the
kid and then it's over and they can't
see the kid anymore
i had to deal with that myself i had to
deal with that i had to it's a double
breakup right so you break up with the
mother and you also break up with a
child and it's like well i've raised you
for this long and now i'm not even
allowed to see like you became my child
do you know what i mean and so it's like
and that's one of the reasons why i tell
men if they do get with women who are
single mothers you need to understand
exactly what you're getting yourself
into you know do you think that the
stepdads should be able to adopt the
kids if they're in the home more than
the actual dad um no
i would say that might depend on the
child
because of how important is for a man to
be in the home i think
that might be the way to go um because
again you know fathers stop children um
stop sons from ending up in prison you
know if if if a child is a scammer a
drug dealer or is involved in any form
of deplorable activity that could land
him in prison it tends to be because the
father isn't there you know if if a
daughter ends up you know in any form of
sex work again it tends to be because
you know the father isn't there and so
if a man is there you know a
stepfather is there and he's he's
stepping up then i i think it makes
sense
for that child to have this ability of
you know be knowing i am adopted by this
man this man is basically my father now
what do you guys think
i think there's potential risks if you
well it depends on the um status of the
relationship i i would personally be
married to the person
um i wouldn't take any risk because you
never know what their intentions are
you've got a young kid you never know if
they're you know rapists and stuff like
that so that's one that's one aspect of
it but i would
agree with you and say that a paternal
figure in a household is essential in
terms of parenting and
yeah
so i would agree
i also think that the child should have
some say at a certain age
um
because if the biological father is
still stepping up to the plate in some
way shape or form then i feel like then
like if the child is old enough they
should have some kind of say because if
they're adopted or not it won't stop the
person being around and if they're of
age they can make that decision to go
and see them if they're even if they're
not adopted
um so i think it really depends
situationally
yeah i agree with both of you guys um
the marriage you know if you're married
to the person you are building up your
future with them they're you know
they've been there for the child um i
say five six plus years
the child's you know of age where that
you know that they can have a say in the
process um i do think the
adoption um would be um essential and
beneficial for for the household and an
option
that should be um
yeah that could that could happen do you
think the child the father should be
able to adopt a child
i don't it's a it's a tough question
right because i think of things from
both sides so on one hand um i i don't
really want to see rights taken away
from the biological debt right
which is why i think it's really
important that it starts at 50 50
custody right but if it's a situation
where it's like an every other weekend
type of thing right
and the step dad's in the house more
than the actual dad i mean it kind of
makes sense
because he's going to have a bigger
impact than the actual dad yeah but the
child this is the thing about that the
child always knows who their biological
father is you could raise a child for
years
right
and that child could not know their
actual biological father but they know
you're not it do you
think kids that are dads that are
raising kids that aren't theirs it's the
same
that's a raisin kids yeah they say um
there's some studies that say like 20 25
of men are raising a child that's not
actually theirs yeah that's very true
yeah what one in 25 fathers
yeah one in 20 i mean it might be lower
one he says one in 25. but i'm asking in
those in those situations what do you do
you think the kids know no the kids
don't know
okay
you're saying does the child know that
this person is not their biological
father yeah because you said like the
kid knows deep down right no i'm not
it's not a deep down thing i'm saying
that
the mother always
the mother's told the child at some
point in time that they've got a dad
right
if a new man arrives the mother's not
going to say oh this is your dad this is
i don't know uncle whoever or this is my
friend or whatever that child still
knows that's not their dad they know
they have one and they know that that
new person is not not the daddy so i
have another question for you guys do
you think because like women we have the
right to an abortion do you think men
should have the right to a financial
abortion
can you explain that so a financial
abortion is basically um
when
so if i'm pregnant right i can say oh i
don't want to be a mother and i can have
an abortion do you think men that don't
want to be fathers should say you know
what i don't want to be on the hook for
child support i don't want to have
anything to do with this kid
and if it was up to me she would get an
abortion but she's not so i want to sign
a reign sign away my rights do you guys
think that men should be able to do that
i think that's fair okay i mean if they
don't get a say
um
in the abortion and they have like
clearly stated i i don't want you to
have this child
um
why not okay i agree i feel like that's
a lot of the issues that we have today
as well with regards to that um
yeah i feel like
they need to be um they should have an
input
yeah i'm so quite 50 50 because if
you've agreed to have the child then
but they didn't they didn't agree yeah
so basically um
he says he wants her to get an abortion
she says no but since she has the right
to say she doesn't want to be a mother
does he have the right to say i don't
want to be a dad yeah
we got some based women today we got
some bass shout out to you guys there's
a lot of psychological problems that can
occur isn't it because you're you've
you've now you've now um was accord
enforced
you you're forcing them basically and
it's just out of their power out of
their world and if they can't
financially care for the child them
yeah
how many dads that are in that situation
get called dead bates yes because if a
dad there's plenty of men that would not
want a child that may not have gone into
a situation wanting a baby
but then when the baby's there is there
that's the reality of the situation
and they may not want to play a part
because they didn't want the child so
they'll get caught a dead beat they'll
get frowned upon by people that know
their situation their family might
disagree especially their families
religious and you've got traditional
backgrounds cultural cultural
underpinnings there'll be a problem
there with that um
oh it's difficult because
i think that you have to take
responsibility before the child is born
before you can see that child yes you
need to take responsibility for where
that
interaction is going
like i agree with you i think men should
take care of their kids but i think it's
one thing to say they should and then
put a gun to their head and force them
to and i just think if we're in a
society that abortion's legal i
personally don't agree with abortion
like if it would be illegal if this was
pearl's world but it's not right and so
abortion is legal so if that's going to
be legal then
then why shouldn't if women get to say i
don't want to be a mother why shouldn't
men get to say i don't want to be a
father
because unfortunately you've had sex and
there's a baby i mean but unfortunately
she's had the same
argument but unfortunately she's had sex
and there's a baby it's the same thing
with like wherever you ain't know
because the child's there yeah but
that's that's the thing even with weight
it's there they just pull out the
body parts one by one crush the head and
suck it out sorry
if the woman gives birth the child is
there i've seen that video by the way i
think we've seen the same thing yeah um
if the child is already there
the child is innocent we no none of us
here asked to be people we're so lucky
to be born right but the child was
innocent in the womb
i'm not advocating abortion i'm just
saying that i know the child's born but
so
looks after the baby
right right so i i agree with you but
i'm saying in this case abortion's legal
so if abortion's legal shouldn't it be
the same for men
shouldn't men get to have a financial
abortion
yes since abortion is legal yeah if you
want that that balance yeah because we
can't obviously give birth ourselves so
yeah i see what you're going with yeah
it's just a bit of a i don't know i
totally agree with what you're saying
like the argument you make is a valid
argument it just makes you feel a little
bit
funny inside yeah we do live in a
gynocentric social order so that's why
it's called the grey area that's it yeah
that's it you got me there so i just um
a point you may or may add to a point
you made earlier about you know if your
stepdad
the the child knows that um you're not
the dad no matter what
i think again that goes back to what i
was saying about that being such a
thankless job you know i was
20 the first time i ever sat down on my
dad and thanked him for being in my life
my whole life right and how many people
can actually say they've ever thanked
their dad for being there not not many
because you just think oh he's meant to
be doing this anyway but it's like
i only deeped it i only realized how
lucky i am to have a dad in my life when
i was in uni and you know a wall broke
in in what our union house we had to pay
for it and i was like oh wait i know how
to fix this because my dad told me and
my dad was around this whole time so
it's a crazy thing that you know your
stepdad would be there so long and the
kid knows it's always that but i think
when that kid grows up if you raise him
well
he will he will most likely thank you
for what you've done for being yourself
i hope so yeah
i actually hope so
for my personal situation
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna read some super
chats real quick um
guys i
who just gifted a bunch of memberships
shout out to you they gifted like 10
memberships
p4g we got a bunch of members in the
chat welcome to our memberships guys
you're going to see exclusive behind the
scenes content on top of that you are
also
going to get the the second half of the
show is going to be members only chat so
you get the members only chat privilege
okay so
nh what's even worse is the csa is a
business the kid only receives a
percentage of the fee sent by the father
i'm sure it's around 40 percent of the
figure the uk economist if mothers were
better at raising kids why are so many
young people in gangs and committing
knife crimes that come from single
mother homes
kai ken there's there this is a grown
man alone and drunk with a woman saying
he's oh i read that one already let me
refresh the page hold on
um
okay
90
free toe pie how are you my little
cayenne pepper i am i'm good i don't
think that like cayenne okay i don't
know how to take this i think he's
taking a liking to you
okay that's all the super chats do you
have any more questions sarah um
[Applause]
you have one okay man all right well go
ahead all right we could do like one
more my question we're talking about if
the man or we always talk about if the
man doesn't want the kid and the woman
wants the kid what if it's the other way
around and the man wants the kid and the
woman doesn't want the kid that's what i
want to talk about i think it's world
that the man has no say at all whenever
that child is born or not like
if i've been in that situation so yeah
you've been yeah it's it's wild like if
i want to if i'm saying i'll take care
of that kid
and you're still having an abortion even
and she can do this even when you're
married like it's ma it's wild it's wild
i i think
i mean i don't think abortion should be
legal so if it was up to me that would
be a legal procedure
what do you guys think do you think men
should have a say in abortion
yeah because it's their is their child
being born as well okay you know i think
it's a joint commitment
in the idle world i would it would be
great to have 50 50
with that but
once you were bought like if a guy wants
the baby right
if the guy wants a baby once you were
bought if he's if you two are together
for instance right and you say you know
what i know we're together but i don't
want this child
does he just is he ever right just leave
you after that
do you think he's just like all right
bye
that's a big thing you know that's a
that's the same as like marriage
if he wants to get married and you
didn't right that at that point in time
and you say like i'm not ready he can
still leave yeah you know i think
because what's he supposed to do like go
to the abortion clinic review to kill
his child at the same time i do think
women
women have to carry the baby it changes
their body it changes you know the
hormones going in in
in their brain in the blood so i do
think at the end of the day it does come
down to the woman but i definitely think
that's why we need to be so careful when
choosing people we sleep with because it
should be a decision that both of you
make together right although it is in
the women's body and everything and
ultimately it does come down to her we
need to be careful who we're sleeping
with
so these issues don't arise you know and
talk about it beforehand i think the
question off camera
is a good one because
we're getting to the point now where you
get the conflation between
what men and women can actually do with
their bodies versus what we think is
morally right right so for me you're
talking about that great area the gray
bit that massive gray area that we're
talking about see because the way i see
it is is that what you've just said
there is spot honest your body
so therefore
i'm on the side of if you don't want the
child then maybe at that point would be
the woman's decision
because she has to go through something
that men can never go through right so
the the constant pursuit of equality in
society this is where it gets messed up
because we're not equal
we can't we cannot give birth as men so
therefore
if the conversation is the woman wants
to have the child
because you're you're the incubator
but the man doesn't want it that's i
think that is a separate debate versus
the same question in reverse because the
physical
uh
the physicality of actually having a
baby
but it's not our body
it's the kid's body it's a unique dna
sequence that's unique from the mother
and the fathers it from the moment of
conception i understand that but i was
just answering the question
so you think she should
have full control
i didn't say full control but i think if
if there is a case where she doesn't
want to have the child
this is where it gets so great i
actually feel like if she doesn't want
to have the child then she should have
the right to say that she doesn't want
to have the child but if she doesn't you
don't it's a different that's a
different question because we're not men
and women are different
but it's sorry this is what i was
wanting to ask like you know
is
plain devil's advocate advocate is is it
her child so is it a body because you
know if she was
let's say the baby was a boy would you
now say she has a dick you know i i
doubt you would because
it's not her body if that makes sense no
but it's her body that's carrying the
baby yeah but you still understand
we understand what you're getting at but
it's like so for example it's me yeah
i'm carrying the baby so if i don't want
to go for the physical changes i have
the right to say not that i agree with
abortion but you can do that eight
months you can change your mind at eight
months
is it different why is it different what
makes you different the process and the
the chemicals
in some states in america you're still
allowed to make that decision well here
you're allowed to up to six months
which is crazy because the earliest baby
that's survived from giving birth is 21
weeks and it's legal at 24.
so a baby that's survived on its own at
21 weeks and at 24 they can still abort
it
and that's what i'm saying what i'm
saying because at what point does it
stop being oh this is my body my choice
because if the argument is my body my
choice then you should be able to abort
up to nine months exactly
which in certain places in america they
were actually advocating for yeah i mean
there's even places in america i mean a
senator got caught talking about how
um if a woman has an abortion and the
baby survives that they can't give that
baby medical treatment yeah
like a senator got caught and planned
parenthood also got caught selling body
parts of children to research clinics
yes they did
but nobody ever cares about that or
talks about that they don't i've got a
solution for all this if the woman
doesn't want to have the child then i'll
take the childhood every day
that's what i do with all my children i
said if you don't have the child i'll
take it full time and you don't have to
have anything to do with it
what you're going to do about the nine
months before
the whole nine months that's almost a
year of her life but again
but it's the same argument you make for
men who have children they don't want
it's like you decided to have sex one at
a time sorry sorry go on
for 18 years i have to look after the
kid
which is why it should be a choice
between the both of you right so what
i'm saying when we're making a choice
we're making a choice of casual sex
we're not making a choice of
having a baby every time not every time
you have casual sex you have the choice
i mean not every time you have casual
sex you want to have a baby right
because you're not a virgin and you
haven't got a child so that means you
you have you're allowed to have the
choice whether or not you're allowed to
have casual sex as a woman as a man we
should be able to have casual sex
without the chance of you getting
pregnant especially when there's so many
contraceptions for you to like
not get pregnant even after the baby's
been conceived no one's saying for you
to wait six months there's a modern
after pill there's a three-day pill
there's there's there's different ways
and i'm saying this to say
we if we had more of a choice maybe it
would be more fairer okay but
respectfully there are also male
contraceptive yes so if you want to have
casual sex take a male contraceptive um
they're not but they're not readily
available at this point male 1 can also
question about the only the only thing
that's available is a condom but girls
can still steal those the nba is issued
statements to nba players saying to
flush your condoms because women are
we're stealing them but you'll heard
what happened with drake okay go ahead
go ahead go ahead can't you reverse a
vasectomy
yeah that's a surge i think there's a
difference between a surgical procedure
which can be irreversible
versus birth control morning after pill
which i mean there are side effects from
sure
but i think we can agree a vasectomy is
like one step further yeah but if
if you want to be having casual sex like
that and you really don't want to
get someone pregnant you're not taking
those precautions beforehand before
sleeping with someone then shouldn't you
do that that's one point that's the
point the same with the women like
shouldn't you do that shouldn't you
think about that before you get an
abortion
so that's why i'm saying like they
shouldn't have a bailout because they
made their bed lie in it are you
advocating for men to have vasectomies
so are you saying no no
no i'm saying if you want to sleep
around and not deal with any of the
consequences like if you're not taking
the time to find out who the woman is
before like if she will listen to your
point of view if you can have a
conversation about it etc then go have a
vasectomy and sleep with whoever you
want you don't have to deal with any of
those consequences you know would you
sorry yeah i was going to say the same
thing for you do you see how do you see
it do you see the double standards
right so for you for you it's my body i
could choose what i want and for me you
should have you should have you should
have took precautions it's your problem
if you have it so now i'm saying to you
if it was it was switched around to you
now and say okay we have casual sex but
abortion is not allowed you have to have
you have to have um the kid you would
soon see how many women not have kids
because they're not going to jump on now
because
because mine could say the same thing
vet who you sleep with why are you
sleeping with someone who wouldn't be a
good father exactly or just get your
tubes tied yeah or get your tears get
your tubes tied at what 18 years old if
you're gonna have casual sex that's it's
a crazy thing to ask a young person to
do right do you know what i mean like
because you don't know what decisions
you're gonna be making into your future
life like to ask to advocate for men
having vasectomies like
to stop them producing sperm
i don't think that's realistic that
that's um an extreme
would you ask your kids
would you ask your kid
sorry could you ask your male son to
take a vasectomy i would say you need to
be careful who you sleep with drunk
right either way that's what we're doing
all right you see there we go now so
you're not gonna you're not gonna do it
for your son you're not gonna do it for
your son you're gonna tell him watch out
the same thing you tell your daughter
watch out do you know what i mean but at
the end of the day the woman still has
the choice whether or not she could have
the kid or not so where we can't have
casual sex as men
we always have to have that something
over us knowing that if anyhow the
condom breaks because it's 99 accurate
it's not 100
so
there's a chance could happen even if we
wear condom but you have a lot of
different ways to stop that kid from
actually being on the earth to the point
of the kid being here so when the kid is
actually here you've passed all of those
contraceptions and now you're saying
that guy is a deadbeat because he's not
around
so you didn't know you didn't know that
before
male contraception should just be more
ready readily available i'm not i'm not
vouching for one or the other i'm just
saying think about who you sleep with
and
there are ways around it i think the
issue is that
you know there's people in states now in
america where abortion's gonna be banned
would you make that same argument to
them that oh it's not that deep just you
know be careful you have sex with and be
careful when you have sex
yes so
no no don't get me wrong i agree i agree
that you should say that yeah i agree
what are you saying he's saying would
you say the same thing to women like be
careful he like now because in in
certain states in the us abortion's
going to be banned so if the girls in
those states would you say the same
thing like it's not that big of a deal
just be careful who you sleep with yeah
okay
it's a choice we have a basic group of
these women today yeah when you look
back at the the history of of
contraception
the liberation of women sexually came
with the invention of the pill
yes so it's in effect
the the the
the get out of jail free card is
actually a bit of a curse in many
respects right because the the casual
nature of having
you know a modern day relationship
normally centers around sex most of the
time
so you've got like you said those
contraceptions in place where you can
actually go and say well you know what i
can go and do my thing because i've got
this pill that pill that implant that
safety yeah but what i want to ask is a
big question
you mentioned contraception and i want
to ask it in the context of abortion do
you guys consider the morning after pill
and pills of that ilk to be abortions i
have gotten this question so many very
interesting gray area
i don't have a good answer to be honest
i've i really want to interview an
abortion and like contraceptive doctor
in the uk about this type of stuff so if
anyone knows anyone in the uk i could
interview i really would like to because
i don't have a good answer i don't know
it's a good question though because i
think it's it kind of is is that great
bit isn't it where you don't is it an
abortion is it not you know because you
could say you
you could say you could say because she
could be pregnant from the night before
she could be that could have been
conception night
right because i i want to say and this
is just from people like coming on my
show and explaining this so this isn't
like
you know factually i haven't double
checked this but i want to say it's the
egg and the sperm have already met and
it's just like it's swimming basically
to the next step and it makes it stop is
that like
i don't know and so i think the argument
is that because the egg and the sperm
have met already
that it could be considered an abortion
arguably i don't know i don't clearly by
the way i explained this is the egg
alive or is the sperm alive
i don't know
okay so
after the morning after would just be
the sperm entering inside of the egg
right
because any girls get rid of their eggs
anyway every month
right men when they have like enjoyment
with themselves
you're getting rid of um sperm as it is
so
all those billions of sperms alive
well they're moving so i guess so yeah
of course
are you mass murdering them
no but i think i think it's because of
the sperm and that but
i don't know i think it's because the
sperm and the egg have already met
in this i don't know we had we had a guy
last week that was mass murdering three
times a day
leave it out
yeah yeah that was a wild show that was
a wild show okay
um because earlier you made a point
about um you know
it being important to be happy in a
marriage and back in the day people
weren't happy and they still stayed in
marriage
a lot of times we say that you know
women weren't happy back then and you
know
relationships were bad and all this
stuff as if we were there and it's it's
funny how
we
look back on history with
2022 lenses
but what how would you explain that
nowadays in 2022
women are on um antidepressants far more
than they were back then even though
like fair enough you could say oh they
didn't have it as much but
what how would you explain that if now
they're allowed to leave relationships
when they want they're still you know
clearly unhappy because antidepressants
then also at that time there are many
mental issues now that are in the dsm-5
now that were not back then yeah i want
to who are you
was that to me sorry
anyone that made the point
i don't know i think a lot of mental
health issues obviously before when
undiagnosed and like you said there is
um
antidepressants are more readily
available now
um i just think there are a lot more for
example social media it's easier to
cheat now but back in the day you don't
have a phone
with you at all times where you could
contact anyone in the world you know so
that's like just one example of things
that are so different that have added
another layer
but don't you think that
when using social media to cheat you
know women can also do that it's not as
if it's only men that can do that so
yeah wouldn't that just mean that
they're both doing things that make them
unhappy in a relationship it's not just
about the man doing something that makes
him unhappy
i don't think i ever said it was just no
i'm not saying that's what you said i'm
just you know raising that point
absolutely like it works both ways in
any situation whoever's going out to
cheers making that decision so so let me
ask you something else do you think it's
right that a woman could leave a
relationship because of a man's
financial situation
when she's got a kid with the person
me
anyone of your ladies i mean no i think
it's selfish i think that's absolutely
selfish if you if you leave a man based
on his financial situation when you have
a kid
because when you have a kid it's not
about you anymore it's about your kid so
if you're mad he's not making enough
money and you're just going to leave
that's selfish especially because you
can get a better paying job also you can
step up and do more yeah i believe that
in that situation it's you're meant to
be a team you know a team so if
someone's going you know if that's
happened to them you think you know what
i mean step up i'm gonna go and get
another another job another side hustle
we're gonna work through this this is
what i'm saying if you're in a
relationship
and you're got children together or
whatnot you're meant to be
doing that partnership anyway and that's
where the mindset should be at
but this is the thing that i think is
quite crazy because everyone talks about
oh i want love in a relationship i want
love in blah blah and the love that
they're talking about is the love that
oh he makes me he makes my insides you
know wiggle oh he does this he does that
and it's all about me sorry me me me
when
if you're going to get married and have
a child
it should be a different sort of love
that you're thinking about it should be
the sort of love where it's like it's a
selfless love so yes i'm not necessarily
happy or i'm not necessarily
in a situation that
i want to be in for the long term but
because i have a childless man and i
decided to bring a child into this world
they're the most important thing here
right now and so they're the thing i'm
focusing on it shouldn't be a situation
with well i'm not happy he doesn't make
enough money so i'm going to leave now
you know that's it's just it's another
level of selfishness that we've seen
become far more prominent in this day
and age yeah but what will happen there
is that you'll have even more mental
health issues
in more sense it's like slavery or
you're obligating people
to
but if you're deciding to have a child
to bring a child into this world you
need to consider that before one before
you have you know you just get married
and two before you have children of
course and then once you make that
decision it doesn't matter how you feel
i know but that's rational thinking
you're dealing with people that have
emotional impulses hypocrisy
well i guess personally
the question are people happier today
than they were a hundred years ago when
the divorce rates were much lower
[Music]
and like that's the thing i think a lot
of times people leave thinking they'll
be happier but you can't depend on
someone else to make you happy only you
can make you happy
and there are exceptions there are
exceptions with like domestic violence
and you know extreme cheating right no
way i think someone could make you happy
someone can make you happy yeah but
that's such a fickle feeling it's such a
fickle feeling it can change so easily
within yourself before you even get into
a relationship before you even have a
child but okay so here's here's my thing
yeah
you said women should be allowed to
decide what they do with their body
right in terms of when it comes to
pregnancy and you and you said as well
that um if the guy steps out too much
then that's the grounds for leaving him
yeah now i want to say to you if he gets
her pregnant the first time he steps out
are you going to leave him
what are the odds of that like come on
you're telling me the first time he
cheated he got it
you're being reckless and like honestly
that's selfish too because you're
putting you're embarrassing your family
would you would you be in the
relationship would i would i leave the
relationship yeah if you had a kid with
someone else screw screw a random hole
one time
no i'll probably stay if i have a kid
but you made a whole ass child with the
random girl that you you have no control
over you no that means like you are
reckless you are reckless and it's
disrespectful it's so disrespectful it's
like come on like if if you have sex
with somebody outside of your marriage
yeah okay but
you you now made an investment from the
next 18 years and you have a marriage
over here like and condoms are 98
effective
condoms are 98 percent effective
and you're telling me you're telling me
that two percent time the first time you
hooked up with her
how many men have casual sex every like
we make it sound like two percent is not
a lot of people two percent of a lot of
people in england's a lot of people but
a lot of men do it wrong let's be honest
don't like using condoms
let's be honest like when early on when
she asks you
your face changed it changed
i i talked to guys all the time and that
like these guys be relying on pull out
with these crazy hoes and i'm like and
you're in a bad situation and i'm like
well
maybe you should and i'm i'm all for
it's mostly on the woman if they get
pregnant but like you got to stop
trusting these girls like
they're not on birth control like they
say they are guys
look at why are you laughing because you
know it's true
maybe women should wear feminines in
school they have them feminines
yeah the female comments don't women
should require the men they sleep with
wear condoms too i'm not i'm not taking
it off the woman but i'm saying like at
this point women have so much power
right they have so much power they can
ruin your life with a kid yeah and they
can they can hold it over there's so
much power why would you give a crazy
girl that much power
it's just not smart it's not smart cause
i was horny man like it and i i'm just
saying like as as a grown man
like
no no wait no no no no no no no no no no
no no no let's not get there let's go
there
but the thing is it's true
don't over talk me this is my show um
okay even kevin samuels talked about
that dick discipline he talks about that
that's one of the core values of a high
value man
you have to have some dick discipline
kevin was a promiscuous man so what dick
discipline how do you know what he had
he died he died he died
he died with on top of a woman that he
heard was she was she pregnant exactly
was she pregnant
you can you can go do your thing but be
smart yeah yeah i get i get that but
what i'm saying to you accidents happen
the man only had one child and he was a
53 year old man like not a problem no no
the godfather is all right you know what
i mean like i'm not really saying it in
the sense of that but i'm saying in
terms of this black men we are not don't
bring don't say black men because i'm
like
men in london
or in the in the west
are more than likely not necessarily
on one woman i can i can believe this
all right please stop saying black men
because you're making men if you want in
it but not
that
sorry
he's like okay okay then why why don't
all these guys have kids exactly why
don't why don't all these men have
because 98
50 percent of men in the u.s that are
black or single and child listen in the
middle class
98 so the 2 is going to be a percentage
of people but i'm saying to you like we
have no control over whether or not kids
say or not in terms of you you you have
no control over what there's too many
conflating issues going on here no okay
you have no after i've had do you have
control of whether you or not you wear a
condom yes okay do i have control
whether or not it bursts or not
arguing about the exception rather than
the rule no no no no no no no no it's
really no no you are because you're you
sound like this is what girls do on my
show they always argue that the
exception it's very feminine uh
wait wait hold on hold on in terms of
the amount of people so when we're
talking about okay if we said two
percent of the world was going to die
tomorrow it's not an insignificant
amount of number so it's not it's not
like i get you when you say the
exception but women will do that in
terms of like the one-off person i'm
talking about two percent even the
one-off first could be five percent it's
still insignificant 99 let's be honest
let's say this this is 99 let me just i
don't know it's not okay guys let me
just say this when you make an argument
it's best to make an argument
with the majority of the percentage with
the rule if you're going to make an
argument with the minority then you're
always going to look like you're trying
to make an excuse
rather than going with the general rule
you're talking about like two percent
right it's like when people talk about
grape and they talk about abortion okay
less than two percent of abortions are
because of grape right you can't argue
the two percent to say oh but what if
but what if bro you're arguing a two
percent argument any problem is the two
percent
argument as the two percent having the
problem if you get what i'm trying to
say we're talking about single
um we're talking about women that have
kids with men that don't want to have
them that's not necessarily a majority
of men so we're talking about that
it's not productive to the conversation
if you're always arguing the exception
two percent two no two percent is the
exception and you're not going to
convince me otherwise like it's not it's
not a good argument i agree with you
that two percent is the exception but
we're talking about the exception in
this case
so no we're not this is my this is my
show we don't talk about the exceptions
we talk about the rule so do you think
the rule is that men are single um that
women are like
i think the rule is that women are more
in control if they get pregnant it's
their own damn fault and i say this all
the time but as a man if you're you have
kids left and right like when do you
learn from your behavior
like when like right i get that you know
and if it's a one time like one kid sure
but if you're having multiple different
baby mamas like that says something
about you and your lack of
responsibility like i'm i'm holding both
sexes accountable i get that if you're
what you were saying
i'd also have a child
okay single single fathers or like um
single parent households is not the
majority that's the exception
now it's like fifty percent
yes it is yes it is
single parent is not the majority we're
talking about the exception in this case
that's a huge that's a huge minority
that's interesting
to you that's not two percent is not a
huge minority
so it's not it's two percent is not a
huge minority of anything
like
in this room how many people are in this
room if you take two percent out of i
don't know the ten people in this room
it might look big but if you if you take
two percent out of
a million what's that and just and just
on a real note and just on a real note
come on most guys that have a lot of
kids aren't wearing condoms right most
guys that are that have a lot of kids
aren't wearing condoms let's just let's
just be real
yes let's just be real how many times
the condom gonna split yeah come on
let's just like honestly be real
agree to disagree i'm just saying that
in terms of like
there's a lot of different reasons why
people are not in
a double
in a
normal relationship in terms of man
woman and kids and it's not necessarily
one reason there's a numerous amount of
reasons okay yes black people black
people there's a higher majority
please don't say black people
because statistically statistically
black people are more than likely in
that single parent household yeah
because 72 of single parent households
exactly but not 72 percent of all
relationships so
do you know what i'm trying to say to
you so i'm saying to you as a majority
of men black men
yeah that you would you say to your guy
all right you're probably having a
single parent household in the white
company in this white
counterpart he would be in a normal
relationship
more than likely that's from choices
what's your point because then why would
it why wouldn't you just do what they're
doing
why wouldn't you just why would we just
take notes because we're dealing with
different problems both so now there's a
reason why hold on there's a reason why
there's a reason why black households
are more than likely not together and it
and it's
and there's a lot to do with but why is
that not true for um african households
so like nigerians are gone exactly my
point that's exactly my point so i'm
going to get to that now so
wait oh no no no no no no no back in the
day
back in the days back in the days black
people were more than likely inside of a
wedding inside of a
marriage
was worse now than enduring slavery say
that again do you think whatever the
black the black community is
experiencing was worse now than during
uh during slavery in in terms of what
context bro every context the their
lives it works
no you can't please please answer the
question yes or though was it worth it
right there no it's working because i'll
tell you why because you're talking
about a small
proportion of black
people i'm asking this specific question
even within that within that community
you're going like
you're going everywhere right
okay okay okay do you think why why can
you ask questions
answer his question it's not a good show
if you're just going to keep going off
on youtube i need you to answer his
question do you think that the black
community okay
in america um specifically america that
their experience their their lived
experience is worse now than it was
during slavery yes or no they live
experience yeah they haven't lived no
no so why is it that back during slavery
black um black families were married
more
sorry um black men and black women are
married more than no i'll tell you why
bro there is an agenda there is an
agenda for black couples not to be
together and what there wasn't one then
back then hold on you were already
enslaved you didn't need to be separated
now that we've now that we've freed you
we have to enslave you in your mind how
we're going to enslave you in your mind
we need to separate your family unit so
basically just just blame hold on a
second in africa it's completely
different to the west
i was complete because in terms of
education in terms of family um dynamics
in terms of community in terms of
marriage in terms of religion in terms
of promiscuity in terms of what you see
on tv in terms of disney what your child
is um brought up by who they're brought
up by where they're left in africa
you're more than likely to be staying in
your great-grandmother's house with your
uncle there with your auntie there with
bubba there with with your fault but
aren't they living the worse than people
here it's more time community looking
aren't they living the worse than people
here more times so how does that explain
the fact that people they're living like
they're like they're not exactly rich
are they they're not exactly you know
they don't have the benefits of living
in the western world and yet they're
still staying together so doesn't that
just say that people mean the people
here there's a there's an issue here yes
and again they were colonized so they
were like it's not as if they weren't
colonized or the white people weren't
there yet we're still not seeing the
same issues so what now
so wait a minute isn't there polygamy in
africa
yes nigeria the influence of
christianity is from where from white
people when they're staying together so
that doesn't make sense i know about
polygamy talking to the mike i need you
to talk to me so polygamy is
is allowed in africa's certain african
countries right yes in certain cultures
yes i don't have any polygamy here
yesterday's not allowed it's illegal
obviously yes we do like if you don't
get married you can have multiple
multiple girls
but marriage is a you know a social
construct right isn't it it is a social
contract but you have to sign
certificates don't you have to do a
ceremony no you can get married without
a without contract but obviously it's
just not but you won't be seen by law
say consummation's marriage because
that's how you stay in the bible so
consummation consummation was actual
marriage in the bible as in what
happened sex
but again it doesn't what you're saying
doesn't debate what i'm saying i love it
because polygamy is not allowed what
does that have to do with condoms
honestly honestly i'm just being real
with you like you just have a bunch of
excuses i'll tell you what it comes down
to paul if you are brought up correctly
you tend to do better things you went
from two percent hold on hold on
if you're brought up correctly you tend
to do better things with your with with
your choices
if you're coming from a single-parent
household you tend to make less
correct
right correct right
so there we go so so now we're safe but
you can still even if you're grown up in
a single parent household i know men
that were that grew up in a single
parent household that aren't getting
girls pregnant left and right because
they make good decisions yeah because
they haven't they probably had a good
parent like myself i was brought up in a
single parent household i've only got
one son and he was planned it was
planned yeah
yeah single parents make up a core
but
again we're talking about that
population we're talking about a
specific population we're talking like
it's not the same thing as what we were
talking about here we're just saying
condoms split two percent of the times
so what you're seeing the conversation
wasn't about that two percent so what
you're saying basically because it's
only two percent yes whatever happens
with where you condemn you're you're
fully responsible because the two
percent is only minuscule the point of
what we're saying
of what we're saying your arguments are
not making sense right if your condom
splits
what can you sue the manufacturer if
you're a condom split
two percent of the time
probably i don't know
he's about to especially
it's a question he's seeking legal
advice he needs a mind right now
because the product didn't work right
yeah but then again she's still got the
choice whether or not she wants to keep
more times of people who are having
babies it's because they're not using
condoms so even your argument doesn't
matter because you didn't have you
didn't use a condom you weren't using
condoms
so it doesn't matter that's that's
incorrect
but okay okay christmas
one off okay but you're telling me men
have multiple children and every single
child was the two percent like
comfortable no that's no that's nothing
you're saying i'll say i'll tell you one
thing the story you told about a girl in
the essay i actually understand what
you're saying because i was in a similar
situation that i understand what you're
saying however more times that's not the
situation and people are just reckless
people are just spreading their seed
everywhere thinking nothing's gonna
happen
there's consequences to actions if
you're deciding to be sexually
promiscuous as a man there's
consequences so take precautions that's
the point yeah but i i get that well you
don't because you're arguing against it
that's i'm not arguing against it yes
you are what have you been doing bro i
am saying to you you're sounding like
you like the sound of your own voice no
no no no no no no no
i can't lie
please if someone understands what i'm
listening i'm saying to you guys this
year
if i have sex with a woman and i have a
condom on it's not a hundred percent
right of course it's not but it's about
i'm doing it sorry
it's not 100
right right we know it's not 100 but
okay let's go with that it's 100
yeah if i had sex with you that means
you don't have you don't have a child
okay
now
if i choose to have sex with you without
a condom does that mean i am saying that
i i am agreeing to have a child with you
both
if a girl is not requiring men to put on
a condom before if before they have sex
she is also being reckless but what i'm
saying is if you keep getting different
[ __ ] pregnant the common denominator
is you
you if you keep finding yourself in the
same situation you may be the problem
it's like it's like future coming here
just like just like if the girl has
multiple baby daddies it might be her
yeah exactly it might be her it's my
future coming in and saying it's not my
fault i have so many i don't agree i
don't agree i don't because if okay you
just want to ask people
bro because i okay if i have casual sex
casual
i do not want to have a kid i want to
have oh yeah
stop obsessing
stop stop i need you to talk i need you
to talk about it just stop having sex
it's not that deep man protect yourself
stop obsessing just stop please don't
touch your penis
guys i really need you to talk into the
mic you think you're talking i'm i'm
just talking for me i'm not talking for
me just for me bro i'm talking about men
i'm talking about men in general
and their ability to have casual sex
that's why
because 2 is a large proportion of
people
that's why i said that you said when you
said
hold on hold on let me finish you said
you said the small percentages doesn't
matter and i'm saying two percent of a
large proportion of people is a lot of
people
a lot of men that have to go through
that and there's no there's no recourse
for it it's just that you was
irresponsible they're not they're not
there's no recourse for what
like i don't i just don't understand
what point you're making
like like i think
can we can we agree that if you keep
getting women pregnant it it might be
your fault right it might be your fault
yes or no
can we agree that if you're a woman that
keeps getting pregnant for other men and
you have multiple babies for baby
fathers it might be your fault
can we agree that most men no that get
because she
she chooses who her baby father is no we
said it's her fault yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah
okay
so we agree okay can i just say can i
just say one point
we're not disagreeing with one point
okay
if you order two percent and you've done
everything right and the condom still
rips
unfortunately that's life
see
you see now you're answering it and that
is fake bro you can't how is that i mean
you just said you said i'm irresponsible
if i don't use a condom you are wait
hold hold on but you're irresponsible if
i don't use a condom but if i use one
it's tough luck if it breaks what else
am i going to say to you
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry life is hard
because actions have consequences and if
you if you don't choose to get married
some guys choose to get married young so
they don't have to deal with this [ __ ]
if you want to be in the streets there's
consequences for being in the streets
this isn't controversial let me say
something if you if your condom breaks
yeah you better have good negotiation
skills that's what i'm saying and wasn't
your original just have good negotiation
skills the original anecdote was if
you're married right with a child and
then you go sleep with someone and then
get them pregnant on the first time
literally wrap your dick up or just be
faithful to your woman it's really not
that hard
practice abstinence that's the best ways
and if you want to have children
abstinence
or just be careful man it's not hard
check who you have sex with and do your
part so that it mitigates the
the chance of that happening it's that
simple i'm glad we feel there's so many
men out black men out here not having
kids i hate when you say oh black men
have this problem no
no none of my friends have this problem
hell do you know what i think we're done
well i think we found a female chess
girl
i think we just found female jessica no
no no
no way there was just a
misinterpretation of what i meant i'm
talking about the two percent guys i'm
not saying i'm not saying that they're
not the majority i'm talking about the
two percent guys yeah where the condom
is burst
are we saying that it's tough luck for
you lot even though women have six
different contraceptions that they could
use to stop you even though you knew i
just wanted to have casual sex but
you're right is that what i said do you
know why your stuff like because you
knew you knew all this stuff for all
these facts before you had sex you knew
that dude so that's why it's tough luck
because unfortunately you took every
precaution there's nothing you could do
and it ripped that's life do you drive i
drive right ninety i've never had an
accident in my car right but it's
possible that i could
right so 99 of the time that i'm driving
on the road i don't have an accident if
i have an accident people say
you couldn't see that coming i never saw
it coming that person might be never saw
it coming but it's part of life
so it's it
it actually [ __ ] what do they say [ __ ]
happens bro okay so single parents but
the thing is but if i say oh um
i should i could say i'm never going to
drive
i could stop driving and say the reason
people can ask me why do you don't you
drive
because there's a two percent chance i
could have an accident and you could
still be here by car
even if you don't drive i mean i mean i
i agree i agree you might actually just
not have sex bro
you know that two percent is there
just like i know the two percent of
having an accident on the street i can
say i'm not going to drive but i drive
yeah also also me personally i've never
switched my life i've never done a drug
overdone other than drink alcohol just
like i've never done anything like that
but i could still get cancer i can still
get cancer right it's life it's not
basically it's just not casual sex and
women could have casualties if that's if
that's what you take from it then fair
enough though
but protect yourself we established it
then protect yourself have as much
intercourse as you want ladies do
whatever you want as much as much as you
want you know it's crazy it makes sense
like why do you why do you like this
this is what i'm sorry you argue like a
girl because this is what girls do is
when they say i said things that i
didn't say i advocate all the time that
women shouldn't sleep around i know
you're just
for no reason that's why no one said
that like wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait i
said i said this
there's a very much um
you're allowed to sleep around i'm not
no no i did not say that you were
allowed to sleep around i don't know i'm
saying that i'm saying i'm saying you're
allowed to sleep around who is allowed
to sleep around anyone that wants to
sleep around is allowed to sneak around
yeah i'm just saying there are
consequences that go with it 100
that's that's my standpoint like you
know i mean you're allowed to do
whatever you want but it doesn't mean
you have to be doing it with me
i forget what i mean
okay so it's not foolproof you know
condoms aren't foolproof you are
choosing to have sex with another person
so what comes with that is also the
understanding that the other person can
make a decision that's going to impact
your life which is why you have to vet
the person why should you have the
responsibility because it's your life
let her engage go on why should why
should why should you why should you be
responsible
why should the men be responsible i'm
saying you can take every precaution but
you still have to be mature enough to
understand that by having sex with this
person pregnancy is a possibility yes
right so if something does go wrong
you might have to live with that
consequence correct yes
okay so know the person you're sleeping
with
don't don't have unprotected sex take
every precaution but if that happens and
the woman doesn't want to avoid it at
the end of the day you made that
decision you had ever you had so many
chances before you could have picked a
different woman there are so many other
things you could do instead of just
blaming the woman that doesn't want to
kill a baby like that
i just don't understand why also also
there's so many people who have sex with
girls who you can tell even if she says
she takes a pill you can tell that
she's not exactly someone who keeps to a
schedule so she might miss a day or two
every now and then and you'll still have
sex and be like oh she's linked she's
like let me just do it that's your fault
you picked her you picked her you can do
everything you can you can use a condom
and still pull out and if you get if she
gets pregnant that's life so if it's the
guy so if the guy is a um is a you knew
he was a abuser well he's a bad boy
no no no no no no no we we're going with
this question yes we're going the same
logic if if she knew he was a bad boy
inverted commerce yeah and then she has
a kid with him then she should stay and
stay with her responsibilities after
because she knew what he was like before
right yes yeah she picked it right there
yes yeah she picked him yeah yes
i'll keep the same energy yes yes
question before if a condom
if a condom is poorly designed or if it
malfunctions the manufacturer could be
held responsible under product liability
law condom manufacturers have a duty to
ensure their products are safe and they
function i asked the question i'm from
america we sue foreign
um all right on the on this note um
we're gonna wrap up the show
um i'm gonna read super chats after i
give everyone their final like thoughts
or whatever so right now we're gonna go
around and everyone's saying final
thoughts tell the people where they can
find you this is a really fun episode um
thank you guys all for coming i really
appreciate it and if you guys have any
thoughts last final comments you got
read super chat them now and i'll read
them after so go ahead
right my name is charlie santam singer
dj talk about politics
during the week uh find me at
charliesandsome.com
hi i'm yasmin you can find me on yes
underscore on screen
before you carry on final thoughts
just i apologize
yeah give any final thoughts you have
i don't have a final thought as such but
just a word
responsibility nice
yup so hi everyone um i'm yasmin
um i'm a life coach and i also have an
apologetic brand
you can find me on yaz underscoring
scormina underscore underscore
and my final word for for today would be
um
understanding and teamwork
um i'm jamella um
my final thoughts
think about who you sleep with
that's it
okay i'm chanelle um you can find me on
youtube as well welcome to shan um and
my final thoughts are
being cooperative parents and
understanding
um my name is jessie praise you can find
me on youtube at jesse praise and take
talk at jesse bray's
um my final thoughts are
you know in the last show i mentioned
that there's a growing population of men
that
lack accountability and i think
if anything this argument showed that
mandem wrap it up if you're gonna do
anything like that women be careful who
you have sex with because they could be
bums you don't know and also
black people please stop blaming society
for your problems yes that has affected
things but us nigerians and ghanaians
were doing good so i don't know amen
i'm doing good too i'm jamaican bro
i said black people i said black people
i said black people don't worry
um yeah sorry god my name is sean
buchanan owner of jerry rider seasoning
my final thoughts are
ladies prepare beware of your
hypocrisies and double standards and men
we have to show more discipline around
sex and abstinence
do you have any where the people can
find you joe seasoning dot co dot uk
and and mr argumentative yeah
listen i i i know the red pill i've been
watching it for a long time and what we
tend to do is preach the choir or use
like
quotes that everyone uses and i'm only
trying to like see it from myself and
not just
preach the choir or repeat what i'm
saying so in the absence of that we
might get into a little bit of back and
forth but it's all love i love pearls i
want to see us i get one million you
know i'm saying if you're here like it
subscribe everything man everybody's
there
um where can they find you oh yeah yeah
i'm here brother just post bro what do
you mean where you can find me i'm here
bro
okay you don't have instagram or
anything you want to plug not really
okay
okay um
i am going to read the super chats guys
thank you so much for all the donations
as you guys know who's trying to see
what ish looks like yay
he's a good looking guy right panel
right panel six foot six yo
yeah he grew since last week
he grew since last week he's six seven
today come on
okay lazy artist um i would say the guys
that does everything right in the condom
still break is probably less than two
percent of guys shawn jackson's condoms
and birth control mitigate risk they
don't eliminate it do what you want but
prepare to eat the cost all this whining
about consequences is unmanly gecko
jesus tell kevin to take his allen tell
karen i said hi black is panther this
guy wants it to be all or nothing like
women do nothing as a guarantee as a man
move accordingly bet this dude was
raised by a single mother black is
panther two percent of a hundred million
is two million it's a lot but it's not
it's not st but it's not statistically
significant chance of it being you is
still low based on overall population
stfu ffs it's called casual because no
babies am i right the uk economist he
wanted to be next amorphous but failed
donkey uspp um i don't know who that is
i don't get the
did he say morpheus morpheus yeah i
don't know who that is pearl this man
can go make you go viral he can't be
this dumb um grapehill male 32 my
sisters bringing kids home from every
man she met was the best birth control
for me my my had my first kid at 27 with
my wife black is panther here we go
instead of taking accountability for my
week pull out game i will blame the
condom comfy company son husband alert
90 free top pearl getting the claws out
girl go pearl go black is panther
scientific scientifically speaking an
exception is considered anything less
than 10
to the other super chat 15 percent is
not an exception 25 is not not an
exception wendell coven pearl may i join
the show in november if you are in
london dm me
alice there actually dm the pregame page
because i am not doing recruiting
anymore thank you jesus um
alistair horton this is why i consider
emotion a weakness and can question
can anyone here name a better situation
where emotion can lead better than
better outcome than logic monkey usopp
you see people this is why you don't
argue for the exception get my man
stuttering his own feudal point
stfu ffs
u.s single parent households 25 percent
uk 15 percent exceptions dude guy mcpans
2 percent means lifetime usage failure
it it and its pregnancy result doesn't
mean two percent of the time a condom
will fail it means a condom will fail
for every two out of a hundred who use
it every single time
s-t-f-u-f-f-s by definition two percent
is the exception ninety-eight percent is
the rule house of household has if a
woman has three abortions in to advance
her career should she be jailed at what
point is it wrong in the abuse of a
child please answer this question um if
it was up to me i would say girls should
go to jail if they get an abortion and
it's illegal but right now it's not
legal or they can't get if it's legal so
obviously they wouldn't be jailed right
now um c women women think that their
sexual passionate matter body count
abortions etc if sexual past doesn't
matter then women should have no issue
with dating men because they used to be
a homosexual stfu ffs conception occurs
minutes or hours before implantation um
stf uffs vasectomy side effects include
testicle explosion a blackest panthera
vasectomy is only 30 reversible after
eight years it's not a magic bullet we
have three forms of birth control women
have 30 but refuse to use any 90 free
topay panel question how many abortions
is too many um for a lady also you
sunburn like a pepper yeah that's true
um i
basketball tournament s-t-u-f-f ffs free
abortions with man mandatory histo
hysterestectomies um david james a cake
blackest panther a man will have to put
his body on the line for 18 years to
work providing child support his body
his choice too johnny 17 202 financial
abortions require both parties be held
accountable that a little bit of
accountability might be
enough to dissuade careless births 90
free taupe oh okay that was the cayenne
pepper let me just make sure there
aren't any more super chats also i
really appreciate all of the new members
this chat guys i know it's a little bit
frustrating having it be members only
for the show but it's really important
that we have members to keep the show
running and keep the lights on in the
studio
um i'm checking super chats one more
time julius may's pearl is beautiful
thank you um
lazy artist i already read that one okay
so guys please please please like the
video on the way out there's over a
thousand of you in here i think there
should be at least 500 likes on this
video it really really helps push out
the content and it helps us in the
algorithm we really want to hit 200k
next month and to get to that goal we
need all of you don't forget to
subscribe to the channel you already
know if you have watched two or more of
our videos and you do not subscribe we
have beef beef people
and thank you for watching we will talk
to you next time bye
peace
that's a wrap